Hello. Now, before we go to today's episode, I have some insanely exciting news for you. On Friday, the 4th of September, Dominic and I will be forming live at the South Bank Centre in London. And better yet, we will be doing something completely new, something that no one has ever heard before on the rest is history. The ultimate Victorian adventure. So to give you just a little taste, we will be in Africa in 18, The Emperor of Abyssinia, Theodore II, has kidnapped 59 Europeans and he is holding them hostage after descending into this demented rage because one of his fellow monarchs, Queen Victoria, has declined to answer his letters. I'm not making this up. And the British, after months and months of fruitless waiting, have lost patience and they have sent a military expedition. under General Napier, halfway around the world to save them, an expedition that includes
大家好。在开始今天的节目之前，我有一些非常激动人心的消息要告诉大家。9月4日星期五，多米尼克和我将在伦敦南岸中心进行现场表演。更棒的是，我们将带来一些完全崭新的内容，这是大家在《历史的剩余》中从未听过的内容：终极维多利亚冒险。为了让大家先睹为快，我们要回到1868年的非洲。阿比西尼亚皇帝西奥多二世绑架了59名欧洲人，并把他们当作人质。因为他的同行君主维多利亚女王拒绝回他的信，他陷入了一种疯狂的愤怒之中。我不是在瞎编。英国人在经历了几个月毫无结果的等待后失去了耐心，他们派遣了一支由纳皮尔将军率领的军事远征军，漂洋过海去拯救他们。这支远征军包括
thousands of mules, loads of elephants, and they've even had to build their own railway across the highlands of Abyssinia or Ethiopia to try to get to his mountain citadel. It is a bonkers story. Yeah, it's absolutely extraordinary, full-blown British imperial epic, full of ludicrous behaviour, mad characters, colossal moustaches, everything that we love on The Rest is History. It is, though I say so myself, a guaranteed classic in the making. So you're probably thinking how can I get a ticket for this extraordinary Victorian adventure? Here is the answer. If you want to get a ticket for this event on Friday, the 4th of September, all you have to do is to go to the rest is history.com.
成千上万头骡子、大量的大象，他们甚至不得不在阿比西尼亚（即埃塞俄比亚）的高原上修建自己的铁路，试图到达他的山地城堡。这是一个极其荒诞的故事。没错，这绝对是一部非同寻常、原汁原味的英国帝国史诗，充满了荒谬的行为、疯狂的人物、巨大的胡子，以及我们在《历史的剩余》中所喜爱的一切。虽然由我自己来说有点自夸，但这绝对是一部注定会成为经典的杰作。所以你可能在想，我该如何买到这场非同寻常的维多利亚冒险之旅的门票呢？答案就在这里。如果你想买到9月4日星期五这场活动的门票，你只需要访问 therestishistory.com。
It is as simple as that. You maybe have to part with some money, but it will be money very, very, very, very well spent. See you there. Hello. Now, before we go to today's episode, I have some insanely exciting news for you. On Friday the 4th of September, Dominic and I will be forming live at the South Bank Centre in London. And better yet, we will be doing something completely new, something that no one has ever heard before on the rest is history. the ultimate Victorian adventure.
就是这么简单。你可能需要花点钱，但这笔钱绝对、绝对、绝对、绝对花得太值了。到时见。大家好。在开始今天的节目之前，我有一些非常激动人心的消息要告诉大家。9月4日星期五，多米尼克和我将在伦敦南岸中心进行现场表演。更棒的是，我们将带来一些完全崭新的内容，这是大家在《历史的剩余》中从未听过的内容：终极维多利亚冒险。
So to give you just a little taste, we will be in Africa in 1868. The Emperor of Abyssinia, Theodore II, has kidnapped 59 Europeans, and he is holding them hostage after descending into this demented rage because one of his fellow monarchs, Queen Victoria, has declined to answer his letters.
为了让大家先睹为快，我们将回到1868年的非洲。阿比西尼亚皇帝西奥多二世绑架了59名欧洲人，并将他们扣为人质。因为他的同行君主维多利亚女王拒绝回复他的信件，他陷入了疯狂的愤怒之中。
I'm not making this up. And the British, after months and months of fruitless waiting, have lost patience and they have sent a military expedition under General Napier halfway around the world to save them. An expedition that includes thousands of mules, loads of elephants, and they've even had to build their own railway across the highlands of Abyssinia or Ethiopia to try to get to his mountain citadel. It is a bonkers story. Yeah, it's absolutely extraordinary, full-blown British. Imperial epic, full of ludicrous behaviour, mad characters, colossal moustaches, everything that we love on The Rest is History. It is, though I say so myself, a guaranteed classic in the making. So you're probably thinking how can I get a ticket for this extraordinary Victorian adventure?
我可没胡编乱造。在经历了几个月的无果等待后，英国人失去了耐心，派遣了一支由纳皮尔将军率领的军事远征军，漂洋过海去拯救他们。这支远征军包括数千头骡子和大量大象，为了到达他的山地堡垒，他们甚至不得不穿过阿比西尼亚或埃塞俄比亚的高原修建自己的铁路。这是一个疯狂的故事。是的，这绝对是非同寻常、原汁原味的英国帝国史诗，充满了荒谬的行为、疯狂的人物、巨大的胡子，以及我们在《历史的剩余》中所喜爱的一切。虽然由我自己来说有点自夸，但这绝对是一部注定会成为经典的杰作。所以你可能在想，我怎么才能买到这场非同寻常的维多利亚冒险之旅的门票呢？
Here is the answer. If you want to get a ticket for this event on Friday, the 4th of September, all you have to do is to go to The Restis History.com. It's as simple as that. you maybe have to part with some money, but it will be money very, very, very, very well spent. See you there. Down through the centuries, the people of Ireland have been fast a wage at continuing an arduous struggle for freedom and equality. For generations, division and despair have scarred the countryside, often alone, often without notice from others throughout the world, brave men,
答案在这里。如果你想买到9月4日星期五这场活动的门票，你所需要做的就是访问 TheRestisHistory.com。事情就这么简单。你可能得花点钱，但这笔钱绝对、绝对、绝对、绝对花得值。到时见。几个世纪以来，爱尔兰人民一直在为继续争取自由和平等的艰苦斗争而付出代价。几代人以来，分裂和绝望在乡村留下了伤痕，他们往往孤立无援，往往不为世界其他地方所注意，勇敢的爱尔兰男人
and women of Ireland have given their lives for the principles they hold dear. Today, the Irish struggle again. The crisis now, however, is especially serious because the hate and bitterness are taking a new and far more drastic turn. Ulster teeters on the brink of a civil war that threatens to engulf all of Ireland. The government of Ulster rules by bayonet and bloodshed. The soaring toll of death and violence is uncontrolled. Thousands flee their homes in terror.
和女人为他们珍视的原则献出了生命。今天，爱尔兰再次投入斗争。然而，当前的危机尤为严重，因为仇恨和痛苦正转向一种新的、远为激烈的方向。阿尔斯特处于内战的边缘，这场内战有可能吞没整个爱尔兰。阿尔斯特政府以刺刀和血腥统治。死亡和暴力的急剧上升失控了。成千上万的人惊恐地逃离家园。
Businesses are bombed and factories close down. Barbed wire roadblocks imprison every street corner. Young children stand on kerbstones and shout shrill in the roadblocks. insults filled with hate. Ulster is becoming Britain's Vietnam. So that was Senator Edward Kennedy taking time off from driving young women into tidal ponds and then pretending it never happened to make a helpful intervention on the plight of Northern Ireland in the United States Congress on the 20th of October, 1971.
企业遭到轰炸，工厂倒闭。铁丝网路障封锁了每一个街角。幼儿站在路缘石上，在路障旁发出尖叫。充满仇恨的侮辱。阿尔斯特正在变成英国的越南。以上是参议员爱德华·肯尼迪在19世纪70年代10月20日借美国国会之机，暂时放下将年轻女性开进潮汐池然后假装什么都没发生的事情，对北爱尔兰的困境发表了一次有益的干预。
And Dominic, this was a speech that went down in Britain like a cup of cold sick. And I suppose the members of the British population who particularly enjoyed it were the Protestant majority in Northern Ireland itself. But having said that, it did go down very well with Catholics in Northern Ireland, didn't it? And indeed, in Ireland more generally. Yeah, absolutely. So, hello, everybody. That was a remarkable attempt on Ted Canada's voice there. I thought, ironically, given their antagonism.
多米尼克，这场演讲在英国引起的反响就像一杯冷呕吐物。我想，英国民众中特别喜欢它的是北爱尔兰本身的抗议者多数派。话虽如此，它在北爱尔兰的天主教徒中确实反响很好，不是吗？实际上，在整个爱尔兰也是如此。是的，绝对是这样的。那么，大家好。刚才那是对泰德·肯尼迪声音的一次非凡模仿。我觉得，讽刺的是，考虑到他们的对立情绪，
It actually sounded more like Jimmy Carter. I know. I finally got there after months of practice. I was trying to make it nasal, and for some reason it went southern. It's great to have Jimmy Carter back on the show, isn't it? Anyway, so this speech, yeah, it kicked off an absolute firestorm of controversy. So the British Embassy in Washington issued a kind of rare statement of rebuke. It said our troops in Northern Ireland are there to stop murder and bloodshed.
它其实听起来更像吉米·卡特。我知道。经过几个月的练习，我终于掌握了窍门。我原本想让它带有鼻音，但出于某种原因，它听起来却变成了南方口音。吉米·卡特能重回节目真是太好了，对吧？不管怎样，这场演讲引发了一场绝对猛烈的争议风暴。因此，英国驻华盛顿大使馆发表了一份罕见的谴责声明。声明称，我们在北爱尔兰的军队是为了制止谋杀和流血事件。
And actually, if a majority of people in Northern Ireland want to join, join the Republic of Ireland, we will not stand in their way. We're not holding them by bayonets and bullets and so on and so forth. And Kennedy's intervention is a sign, I think, of just how toxic Northern Ireland had become for Britain, for the image of Great Britain in the early 1970s. And his comparison with Vietnam, which was incredibly controversial in late 1971, given what was happening in Vietnam, was it accurate? Well, it's not that far-fetched. So at this point, at the end of 1971, about 200 people have been killed. Of course, nothing by the numbers being killed in Vietnam.
事实上，如果北爱尔兰的大多数人想要加入爱尔兰共和国，我们不会阻拦。我们没有用刺刀和子弹扣留他们，诸如此类。我认为，肯尼迪的干预表明，在20世纪70年代初，北爱尔兰对英国以及英国的形象来说是多么具有毒性。他将其与越南进行比较，鉴于越南当时发生的事情，这在1971年底引发了难以置信的争议，这种比较准确吗？嗯，其实也并非那么离谱。所以在1971年底这个时候，大约有200人丧生。当然，这与越南的死亡人数相比微不足道。
But the spectacle of an army trapped in a quagmire, you know, where it's hard to tell friend from foe, where there's no political solution in sight. I mean, there's a lack of napalm, isn't there? There is a lack of napalm, but there is the sense of a conflict spiraling out of control and politicians haplessly struggling to keep up. I mean, there are definite dissimilarities, no question. Sure. But rather as the Americans, when they first went into Vietnam, thought, well, this will be done and dusted quite quickly and we'll be able to go home. Similarly, when the British sent in the army, as we heard last time, in the late summer of 1969, and of course they sent troops to protect, largely to protect the Catholic populations of Belfast and London Derry. They thought, well, hopefully we'll be home, not by Christmas, but within a few months. And the story of today's episode is how all of that went wrong. How did things become so bitter and so murderous, so quickly, in a way that would lead outside observers to make a comparison with what was going on in Vietnam?
但一支军队陷入泥潭的景象，你知道的，在那里很难分清敌友，看不到政治解决的希望。我的意思是，这里缺少凝固汽油弹，对吧？确实缺少凝固汽油弹，但有一种冲突失控的感觉，政客们在苦苦挣扎却无能为力。我的意思是，毫无疑问，它们之间存在着明显的不同。当然。但正如美国人最初进入越南时认为，这一切很快就会结束，我们就能回家一样。同样，正如我们上次听到的那样，当英国人在1969年夏末派军队进去时，当然，他们派军队是为了保护，主要是为了保护贝尔法斯特和伦敦德里的天主教人口。他们以为，好吧，希望我们能回家，不是在圣诞节前，而是在几个月内。今天这一集的故事讲的就是这一切是如何走向错误的方向的。事情怎么会变得如此痛苦，如此充满杀戮，速度又是如此之快，以至于让局外观察家将之与越南正在发生的事情进行比较？
So let's kick off by reminding ourselves where we got to last time. So we had Northern Ireland established in the 1920s with this deep sort of fractalite, Protestant majority, Catholic minority, the Catholic minority feeling that they're treated like second class citizens and everything from jobs to housing. In the first episode last week, we talked about how things started to spiral downhill in the mid-1960s. Terence O'Neill's attempts to modernise, Ian Paisley's inflammatory kind of rhetoric, the anniversary of the Easter Rising, the first killings by the Ulster Volunteer Force in 1966. And then last episode, the emergence of the Catholic Civil Rights Movement, this sort of increasing sense of confrontation, the Battle of the Boggs'Its' as it was called in Derry, and Wilson and Callahan agreeing to send in the troops. So let's pick up the story in the midsummer of 1970, and specifically we're on the 21st of June.
那么让我们首先回顾一下我们上次讲到哪里。北爱尔兰成立于20世纪20年代，有着这种深刻的分裂，即多数派是新教徒，少数派是天主教徒，天主教徒觉得他们在从工作到住房的方方面面都受到二等公民般的对待。在上周的第一集中，我们讨论了事情是如何在20世纪60年代中期开始走下坡路的。特伦斯·奥尼尔的现代化尝试，伊恩·佩斯利的煽动性言论，复活节起义的周年纪念，1966年阿尔斯特志愿军制造的第一起谋杀案。然后在上一集中，天主教民权运动的兴起，这种不断升级的对抗感，德里所谓的“博格赛德之战”，以及威尔逊和卡拉汉同意派兵。让我们把故事拉回到1970年的仲夏，具体是在6月21日。
Now, Harold Wilson, with his shiny Gannock's raincoat, is out. He's gone. He's gone from the story. He has lost the election. He lost it three days earlier on the 18th of June. And so, Tom, we welcome back to the show, a great yachtsman, a great organ scholar, but a man who hates of traditional county, and that man is Ted Heath, the worst man in history, apart from Jimmy Carter. You think Ted Heath is the worst man than Jimmy Carter? What he did to Rutland is unforgivable. Yeah. And the ridings. Mad counties, mad counties, and Heath is personally to blame. I think that's the takeaway from this series. So Heath, the leader of the Conservative Party, has just won the general election. He hasn't talked to all about Northern Ireland. He's talked about overhauling the British
现在，穿着亮眼麦金托什雨衣的哈罗德·威尔逊已经出局了。他走了。他退出了故事。他输掉了选举。他在三天前的6月18日输掉了选举。所以，汤姆，我们欢迎节目迎来一位新嘉宾，一位伟大的帆船手、一位优秀的管风琴学者，但也是一个厌恶传统郡县的人，他就是泰德·希斯，历史上仅次于吉米·卡特的最糟糕的人。你觉得泰德·希斯比吉米·卡特还糟糕吗？他对拉特兰做的事是不可原谅的。还有那些选区。疯狂的郡，疯狂的郡，希斯要对此负个人责任。我想这是本系列得出的结论。因此，保守党领袖希斯刚刚赢得了大选。他根本没怎么谈过北爱尔兰。他谈的是彻底改革英国
economy to get rid of all the lame ducks in industry. But I mean, he's a conscious modernizer, isn't he? So he would have no interest in Northern Ireland, which he would see as a kind of antediluvian 17th century bog. Completely. Completely. And of course, he wants to be friendly to Britain's neighbours because he wants to get us into the common market. So Britain will join along with Ireland in 1973. Ted Heath would astound you to hear, given what we were saying Britain's politicians in the last episodes has absolutely no knowledge of Northern Ireland and no interest in it whatsoever.
经济，除掉工业中的所有“跛脚鸭”。但我的意思是，他是一个自觉的现代化主义者，不是吗？所以他对北爱尔兰不会有任何兴趣，他会把北爱尔兰看作是一个陈旧的17世纪的泥潭。完全是这样。当然，他希望对英国的邻国友好，因为他想让我们加入共同市场。所以英国将在1973年与爱尔兰一起加入。考虑到我们在前几集里对英国政客的评价，泰德·希斯对北爱尔兰完全一无所知，也毫无兴趣，听到这里你可能会大吃一惊。
So on the 21st of June, which is where we're kicking off, the Cabinet Secretary has the excellent name of Sir Burke Trend. Sir Burke Trend. Yeah, that's his name. That's an insane name. Well, that's his name. American-style name. I'm never going to be rude about an American name again.
所以在6月21日，也就是我们开始的时候，内阁秘书有一个非常棒的名字叫伯克·特伦德爵士。伯克·特伦德爵士。是的，这就是他的名字。这是一个疯狂的名字。好吧，这就是他的名字。美式风格的名字。我再也不会对美国名字粗鲁了。
So Sir Burke Trend sends him this briefing document and says, okay, this is the situation. You know, I'm going to tell you everything you need to know about Northern Ireland. And Sir Burke says to him, it's now 10 months since we're sent in the army, and we hope to bring them home quickly, but obviously that ship has sailed. And he says there are basically two scenarios. That's the best case scenario is that things stay exactly as they are, and I quote, stabilised by the presence of British troops and trembling on the edge of disaster but never quite tipping over. And Berk-Tren says the downside is that way's going to be very expensive in terms of men and money.
所以伯克·特伦德爵士发给他一份简报说，好吧，这就是目前的形势。你知道的，我要告诉你关于北爱尔兰你需要知道的一切。伯克爵士对他说，我们派军队进去已经10个月了，我们曾希望迅速把他们带回家，但显然那艘船已经开走了。他说基本上有两种情况。最好的情况是事情完全保持原样，我引用一下，“由英国军队的存在维持稳定，在灾难的边缘颤抖，但从未真正倾覆。”伯克-特伦德说，坏处是这种方式在人员和金钱方面代价将非常高昂。
However, that's the rosy scenario. The worst possibility as follows. It could get worse and finally tip over the edge, the Northern Ireland government proving incapable of holding the position, civil war breaking out within the province, and Dublin being compelled to intervene. This would present us with a political and constitutional crisis of the first order. I mean, Dominant, you compared it, well, Edward Kennedy did, to Vietnam.
然而，那是乐观的情况。最坏的可能性如下。情况可能会恶化，最终越过边缘，北爱尔兰政府证明无力控制局面，省内爆发内战，都柏林被迫干涉。这将给我们带来一级政治和宪法危机。我的意思是，多米尼克，你把它比作越南——爱德华·Kennedy就是这么做的。
Yeah. But actually, what it sounds like is Iraq or Afghanistan. the briefings that American presidents were probably getting in the wake of the attempt to stabilize those governments. Yeah, you're not wrong. And actually, we will see there are attempts to basically do a sort of general David Petraeus-type surge. You know, in this similar kind of debates, do we get out, do we put in more troops? What do we do? Do we spend good money after bad, as it were?
但实际上，这听起来像是伊拉克或阿富汗。这是美国总统在试图稳定这些政府之后可能收到的简报。是的，你没说错。事实上，我们会看到有人试图基本上搞一次类似戴维·彼得雷乌斯将军式的增兵。你知道，在类似的辩论中，我们是撤军还是投入更多军队？我们该怎么办？我们是不是在把好钱扔进无底洞？
It's not a bad comparison at all. So that's the picture. But what Serbirk Trend and Ted Heath do not know is that at this point, a new factor is about to enter the equation. Now, one group that we actually haven't talked about that much, which may surprise some listeners, is the Irish Republican Army, the IRA. And the reason that, as we've talked about before, they had this border campaign that failed by 1962. The leadership of the IRA abandoned guerrilla violence. They put on their polo necks, and they turned to kind of. Marxism and hanging around with academics. And they thought about, you know, they thought the future
这个比喻一点也不坏。这就是情况。但伯克·特伦德和泰德·希斯不知道的是，此时此刻，一个新的因素即将加入这个方程。现在，有一个我们其实没有怎么谈论过的组织，可能会让一些听众感到惊讶，那就是爱尔兰共和军，简称爱尔兰共和军。原因在于，正如我们之前所讨论的，他们曾在1962年失败了一场边境战役。爱尔兰共和军的领导层放弃了游击暴力。他们穿上高领毛衣，转向了某种马克思主义，开始和学者们混在一起。他们思考，你知道的，他们认为这个运动的未来
of this movement is a workers' alliance to beat capitalism as well as imperialism. And that meant that during all the disturbances in 1969 that we talked about last time, the IRA are actually quite quiet. And graffiti went up in Belfast that summer. IRA equals I ran away. Now, if you're an older IRA man, if you've been active in that guerrilla movement, since, let's say, the 1940s even longer, you are very embarrassed by this. In fact, you're positively furious. So these older IRA veterans, often they're kind of cultural conservatives, very strongly Catholic. They don't have any truck with the Marxism and whatnot.
是一个工人联盟，以击败资本主义和帝国主义。这意味着在我们在上一期节目中谈到的1969年的所有骚乱期间，爱尔兰共和军其实相当安静。那年夏天，贝尔法斯特出现了涂鸦：爱尔兰共和军等于我逃跑了（IRA = I ran away）。现在，如果你是一个老资格的爱尔兰共和军成员，如果你自40年代甚至更早以来一直活跃在那个游击运动中，你对此会感到非常尴尬。事实上，你简直怒不可遏。所以这些老一代的爱尔兰共和军老兵，通常他们是某种文化保守派，天主教色彩非常浓厚。他们根本不理会马克思主义之类乱七八糟的东西。
They're really fed up with this. They're like, why are we not getting stuck in? And then the other group, who I think are really important, are the younger militants, often in their late teens, early 20s, people who've seen action in the street fight. in Belfast and Derry in 1969. And they similarly think the IRA has basically vacated its historic role as the defender of the Catholic people of Northern Ireland. Someone should take up arms to defend our people against the loyalists and the IUC and all of this. And this comes to a head in December 1969.
他们对此真的厌烦透顶。他们会想，我们为什么不卷入其中呢？然后是另一个我认为非常重要的群体，那就是年轻的激进分子，通常处于二十岁左右的晚期，即那些在1969年的贝尔法斯特和德里街头战斗中亲历过战火的人。他们同样认为，爱尔兰共和军基本上放弃了其作为北爱尔兰天主教人民保卫者的历史角色。应该有人拿起武器来保卫我们的人民，对抗保皇党、IUC和这一切。这在1969年12月达到了一个高潮。
There's a secret meeting of disaffected IRA men in Belfast. And they agree that they were split from the Marxist leadership. and they will set up their own rival IRA executive and army council, as they're called. And they call themselves the provisional IRA, partly to echo the text of the proclamation in the Easter rising of 1916, which had set up a provisional government of Ireland. And what happens to the original IRA? Were they still hang around? They have the official IRA.
贝尔法斯特的不满的爱尔兰共和军成员举行了一次秘密会议。他们同意脱离马克思主义领导层，建立他们自己的对手爱尔兰共和军执行委员会和军队委员会（他们是这样称呼的）。他们自称为“临时派爱尔兰共和军”，部分是为了呼应1969年复活节起义宣言的文本，该宣言曾建立了一个爱尔兰临时政府。原来的爱尔兰共和军怎么样了？他们还在周围闲逛吗？他们有“正式派爱尔兰共和军”。
And are they still a going concern today? They effectively wound up their operations in the early 1970s. But they are still active in the period of this series. Right. So they have gunmen. They have weapons. They have seminars. Yeah.
他们今天还在运作吗？他们在20世纪70年代初实际上结束了他们的行动。但他们在这一系列事件的时期仍然很活跃。对吧。所以他们有枪手。他们有武器。他们有研讨会。是的。
Well, they become radicalized to try and compete with the provisionals, actually. So they sort of take up the gun as well. But they end up merging, do they? Basically. No, they don't merge. I mean, there's also the INLA, which we don't need to get into them. You know, this is the nature of paramilitary groups. They tend to splinter.
嗯，他们实际上变得激进化了，试图与临时派竞争。所以他们也拿起了枪。但他们最终合并了吗？基本上。不，他们没有合并。我的意思是，还有INLA（爱尔兰国家解放军），我们不需要深入探讨他们。你知道，这就是准军事组织的性质。它们往往会分裂。
Yeah, of course. So 10 days after this, so the. provisional IRA issued their first public statements. And they said, we're going to defend our people in the north. We're going to fight for the full political freedom of Ireland. And then early January, 1970, the political wing of the IRA, so it had always had this allied political party called Sinn Féin, that split into official and provisional factions on the same lines. And of course, as anyone who remembers the 1970s natism will know, it is the provisional IRA, the provos, that they are the people who dominate the headlines in Britain and in Ireland in the next
嗯，当然。所以在这之后的10天里，临时派爱尔兰共和军发表了他们的第一份公开声明。他们说，我们要保卫我们在北方的同胞。我们要为爱尔兰的完全政治自由而战。然后是1970年1月上旬，爱尔兰共和军的政治翼，因为它一直有一个名为新芬党（Sinn Féin）的盟友政党，该党沿着同样的路线分裂成了官方派和临时派。当然，正如任何熟悉20世纪70年代新闻的人所知，正是临时派爱尔兰共和军（即“普罗沃斯”），在接下来的大约30年里，他们成为了主导英国和爱尔兰头条新闻的人。
30 years or so. So just to talk about them, because they are the group that everyone knows as the IRA. A couple of really important points. Sometimes when you're reading about them, you will see people say, well, they were basically set up as a defensive organisation. They were set up to defend Catholic communities from attacks by Protestant mobs in 1969. And that's where the provisional came from. This is really just not true at all. So almost all of the original leaders of the provisionals. We'll talk about them a bit later, but a guy called Sean McSiefen, Ruria Brady, Davy O'Connell, Billy McKee. These are long-standing IRA men. These are people who have been in the IRA for 10, 20, 30 years. A lot of them have served time in prison, in Britain or in Ireland.
所以，来谈谈他们吧，因为他们是每个人都知道的那个爱尔兰共和军。有几个非常重要的点。有时候当你阅读关于他们的资料时，你会看到有人说，好吧，他们基本上是作为一个防御组织建立的。他们是为了在1969年保卫天主教社区免受新教暴徒的袭击而成立的。临时派就是这么来的。这其实根本不是真的。因此，临时派几乎所有的最初领导人——我们稍后会讨论他们，但有一个叫肖恩·麦克斯特芬（Sean Mac Stiofáin）、鲁里·布雷迪（Ruairí Ó Brádaigh）、戴维·奥康奈尔（Davy O'Connell）、比利·麦基（Billy McKee）的人——都是资深的爱尔兰共和军成员。这些人已经在爱尔兰共和军待了10年、20年、30年。他们中的许多人曾在英国或爱尔兰的监狱里服刑。这些都是深信利用武力来获得一个统一的爱尔兰的准军事人员。现在，与爱尔兰共和军相关的更年轻的人也来自长期的共和党家庭。让我们看看一个人，他非常、非常坚决地否认自己曾是爱尔兰共和军的一部分。你能猜出这个人是谁吗？这难道是杰瑞·亚当斯吗？正是杰瑞·亚当斯。所以我们要记录在案，他的确否认自己加入过爱尔兰共和军。他绝对否认自己加入过爱尔兰共和军。
These are paramilitaries who are, you know, they believe in using force to get a united Ireland. Now, even younger people associated with the IRA come from longstanding Republican families. Let's look at one person who very, very vigorously denies that he was ever part of the IRA. Can you guess who this person is? Is this Jerry Adams by any chance? It is Jerry Adams, yes. So we're just putting on the record that he does deny he was in the IRA. He absolutely denies he was in the IRA.
关于杰瑞·亚当斯，奇怪的是他否认自己加入过爱尔兰共和军，但每一位撰写相关历史的学术历史学家都相信他曾加入过。所以很难知道该相信谁，汤姆。因此，当临时派成立时，杰瑞·亚当斯21岁。杰瑞·亚当斯本人总是说：“我是通过民权运动被吸引到共和主义活动中来的。我之所以激进并加入新芬党，是因为我对保皇党的暴力感到太震惊了。”对于向美国受众传达信息时所做的架构来说，这一点很重要，不是吗？
The strange thing about Jerry Adams is Jerry Adams denies that he was in the IRA, but every single academic historian who writes about this believes that he was. So it's hard to know who to believe there, Tom. So Jerry Adams was 21 years old when the provisionals were established. Jerry Adams himself has always said, I was drawn into Republican activism through the civil rights movement. I was radicalized to join Sinn Féin because I was so shocked by the loyalist violence. That's important, isn't it, for the framing of the message for American audiences?
因为如果你把自己塑造成站在民权运动这一边的人，我的意思是，谁会反对呢？是的，谁会不同意呢？现在，必须要说的是，杰瑞·亚当斯在这里所说的关于自己是以这种方式变得激进的话根本不是真的。杰瑞·亚当斯来自西贝尔法斯特的一个共和党家庭。他的祖父在20世纪20年代是爱尔兰共和兄弟会的成员。他的父亲是爱尔兰共和军成员。他的叔叔们也是爱尔兰共和军成员。他的父亲曾因伏击警察巡逻队而入狱。
Because if you cast yourself as being on the side of the civil rights movement, I mean, who would object to that? Yeah, who would disagree with that? Now, it's important to say what Jerry Adams is saying here about being radicalized this way is just not true. Jerry Adams comes from a Republican family in West Belfast. His grandfather was a member of the Irish Republican Brotherhood in the 1920s. His father was in the IRA. His uncles were in the IRA. His father was jailed for an ambush on a police patrol.
所以，假设杰瑞·亚当斯说的是真的，他从来都不是爱尔兰共和军的一部分。对我和我的困惑在于他为什么不是，因为鉴于他的背景，如果他不加入才真的很奇怪，我想说。然而，你知道，世界真奇妙，不是吗？所以也许他真的没有加入。现在，另一点是关于暴力的。
So let's assume that Jerry Adams is telling the truth, and that he was never part of the IRA. The puzzle for me is why he wasn't, because given his background, it would be very strange for him not to have joined it, I would say. However, you know, it's a funny old world, isn't it? So maybe he wasn't. Now, the other point is about violence.
与民权运动不同，临时派爱尔兰共和军对改革斯托蒙特（Stormont）政权不感兴趣。不，他们想摧毁它，不是吗？他们不想摧毁它吗？他们想要推翻斯托蒙特，他们想要赶走英国人，他们想要一个统一的爱尔兰。他们将要实现这一目标的方式
The provisional IRA, unlike the say in the civil rights movement, are not interested in reforming the Stormont state. No, they want to destroy it, don't they? They don't want to destroy it? They want to bring down Stormont, they want to drive out the British, and they want a united Ireland. And the way that they're going to do that
就是他们委婉地称为“肉体力量”的东西。也就是暴力。他们对此完全是直言不讳的。因此，这是1970年9月的《共和党新闻》。它说：“爱尔兰人民应该认识到，英国帝国主义者不会尊重、害怕或过多关注那些为施舍或让步而乞求、卑躬屈膝或爬行的人。”换句话说，只有当你进行反击时，他们才会尊重你。
is what they call euphemistically physical force. And that is violence. And they're completely upfront about that. So this is the Republican news in September 1970. It says, the Irish people should realize that British imperialists do not respect, fear, or pay much attention to people who beg, grovel or crawl for favours or concessions. In other words, they only respect you if you fight back.
当然，爱尔兰共和军会说——而且他们自始至终都在这样说——会有平民伤亡，但这是一场战争。这是不可避免的。这是值得的。你知道，我们会做可怕的事情，但为了得到我们想要的东西，这是值得的，目的将证明手段的正当性。这就是为什么当你进入20世纪90年代末时，老一代共和主义者常常对《耶稣受难日协议》以及爱尔兰共和军最终接受的交易感到如此被背叛。你所说的老一代共和主义者是指比他们更早一代的人吗？是的，但也包括那些自70年代以来就身在其中的人。如果你在1970年加入，对吧，你当时20岁，那么当你一切都结束时，你差不多是什么年龄？五十多岁了吧。而你生命中最美好的部分，
Now, of course, the IRA say, and they say this throughout, there are going to be civilian casualties, but this is a war. That is inevitable. It is worth it. You know, we're going to be doing terrible things, but it is worth it to get what we want, and the end will justify the means. And that is why, when you get to the late 1990s, that is why the older Republicans often feel so betrayed by the Good Friday Agreement and the deal that the IRA ended up taking. And by the older Republicans, you mean people who are from a generation before? Yeah, but also people who've been in there since the 70s. If you joined in 1970, right, and you're 20 years old, you are what, getting into your 50s, maybe by the time it all comes to an end. And the best part of your life,
你知道的，你的黄金岁月已经过去了。你已经把那些黄金岁月用来做那些你知道是非常可怕的事情。你杀过无辜的人，但你这样做是因为你相信目的是正当的，而目的是一个统一的爱尔兰。现在你的领导人告诉你，实际上，你这么做是为了能与伊恩·佩斯利（Ian Paisley）组建联合政府并去管理供水局。而你说，什么？我的意思是，我们涉足血海。我们堕入地狱。我们基本上，你知道，为了这个出卖了我们不朽的灵魂。这就是为什么当杰瑞·亚当斯和马丁·麦吉尼斯达成交易时，人们会感到如此委屈。我的意思是，你提到了地狱和不朽的灵魂。是的。在那个语境下。我的意思是你是用隐喻吗？
you know, your prime years are behind you. And you've, and you've, spent those prime years doing things that you know are terrible things. You have killed innocent people, but you did it because you believed the end justified the means and the end was a United Ireland. And now your leaders tell you, actually, you did it so that you could get into coalition with Ian Paisley and run the waterboard. And you say, what? I mean, we waded through blood. We descended into hell. We basically, you know, sold our immortal souls for this. And that's why people feel so aggrieved when Jerry Adams and Martin McGuinness do the deal. I mean, you mentioned hell in immortal souls. Yeah. In that. I mean, do you mean that metaphorically?
还是我们在谈论那些真正认为自己冒着失去不朽灵魂风险的人？我认为有相当多的人是非常虔诚的天主教徒。我们确切地知道，许多爱尔兰共和军成员都是虔诚的天主教徒。我的意思是，他们相信这些东西。你知道，他们生活在一个被宗教圣像包围的世界里。爱尔兰共和运动的圣像具有非常、非常、非常浓厚的天主教色彩。我想当你阅读对人们的采访，当他们回首自己的生活时，他们是在回顾自己所做的事情。
Or are we talking about people who genuinely think that they have risked their immortal souls? I think there are quite a lot of people who are very pious Catholics. We know for a fact that a lot of IRA men were pious Catholics. I mean, they believe in this stuff. You know, they live in a world where they're surrounded by religious iconography. The iconography of the Irish Republican movement is very very, very heavily Catholic. I think when you read interviews with people, when they're looking back at their lives, they're looking about what they did.
很显然，你知道，他们沉浸在某种宗教文化中。而且我认为很多人确实觉得，你知道，我们做了可怕的事情，但我们是以更伟大的善的名义去做的。是的。你知道，我们被出卖了。我的意思是，这显然总是让人感到困惑。
They're obviously, you know, they're steeped in a kind of religious culture. And I think a lot of people did feel, you know, we did terrible things, but we did it in the name of greater good. Yeah. You know, and we've been sold out. I mean, this is obviously always puzzles people.
为什么持续派爱尔兰共和军（Continuity IRA）或真实爱尔兰共和军（Real IRA）之类的不坐下来开会并接受《耶稣受难日协议》呢？好吧，我想这就是原因，因为他们只是感到被背叛了。不管怎样，我们话题扯得太远了。回到1970年初。所以临时派已经建立，他们的首要任务是弄到枪，而他们有强大的朋友来帮助他们做到这一点。
Why did the continuity IRA or the real IRA or whatever? Why didn't they just get around the table and accept the Good Friday Agreement? Well, I think this is why, because they just felt betrayed. Anyway, we're jumping ahead too much. Back to early 1970. So they've been set up the provisionals, their priorities to get guns, and they have powerful friends to help them do it.
首先，他们在爱尔兰共和国有朋友。这实际上是一个非凡的故事。我认为它在英国并不是非常广为人知。1969年，爱尔兰政府拨出了10万英镑作为对被赶出北方家园的天主教家庭的救济基金。基本上至少有两名爱尔兰政府部长。因此，查尔斯·霍西（Charles Haughey，后来的爱尔兰总理，也就是首脑“T-Shook”），是的，还有一个叫尼尔·布莱尼（Neil Blaney）的人。
So first of all, they have friends in the Republic of Ireland. This is an extraordinary story, actually. I don't think it's terribly well-known in Britain. In 1969, the Irish government had put aside £100,000 pounds as a sort of relief fund for Catholic families driven from their homes in the north. And basically at least two Irish government ministers. So Charles Hohy, later the Prime Minister of Ireland, the boss, the T-Shook, yeah, and a guy called Neil Blaney.
他们与一个曾加入党卫军（SS）的比利时商人合作使用这笔资金。他们挪用这笔资金在西德购买枪支，并将它们走私给爱尔兰共和军。这在爱尔兰共和国是一件大事。为此曾有过一场巨大的法庭诉讼。另一个地方是美国。当然，许多爱尔兰裔美国人，许多对故国有着某种，你知道的，如梦幻般记忆的爱尔兰裔美国人，对英国有一种本能的怀疑和厌恶。包括泰德·肯尼迪。包括泰德·肯尼迪。
They collaborated with a Belgian businessman who had been in the SS to use this money. They diverted the money to buy guns in West Germany and they smuggled them to the IRA. This was a huge deal in the Republic of Ireland. There was a huge court case about it. And then the other place is America. Of course, lots of Irish Americans, lots of Irish Americans with very sort of, you know, misty-eyed memories of the old country, an instinctive suspicion and dislike of Britain. Including Ted Kennedy. Including Ted Kennedy.
你还有像诺拉黑（Noraid）这样的组织，最著名的是，他们从爱尔兰裔美国人那里筹集资金。其中很大一部分资金用于购买在加利福尼亚制造的阿玛莱特（Armalite）步枪。然后它们被走私过大西洋，令人惊奇的是，他们甚至会把阿玛莱特步枪藏在“伊丽莎白女王二号”邮轮上走私过去。哦，就像卢西塔尼亚号一样。是的，完全是这样。因此，到1970年夏天，临时派拥有了相当强大的军火库。他们有突击步枪，有半自动武器。他们有大约1000名活跃成员，这些人不仅会上街战斗，还负责经营安全屋之类的地方。他们在1970年6月底上演了宏大的登场。现在，希斯，泰德·希斯在现代英国历史上有过无与伦比的记录，我认为他做出了意图良好但灾难性的政治误判。所以他的第一次误判，这是1970年的夏天，你要禁止传统的工会游行、奥兰治秩序游行之类的事情吗？他说：“不，我不会那样做。”
And you have groups like Norahe, most famously, they raise money from Irish-Americans. A lot of that money goes to buy armolite rifles, which were made in California. And then they are smuggled across the Atlantic, including, amazingly, they would smuggle armolites across on the QE2. Oh, so like the Lusitania. Yeah, exactly. So by the summer of 1970, the provisionals have a pretty serious arsenal. They've got assault rifles, they've got semi-automatics. They've got about 1,000 active members, and that's people who are going to go and fight
因为我刚当上首相。我不想疏远北爱尔兰的新教徒观点。但同时，你刚才说他对北爱尔兰一无所知。不，他不知道。这是真的。公平地说，他听从了建议。他最后确实住在索尔兹伯里，所以我偶尔要为他的事业呐喊助威。好吧，我们要为泰德·希斯撑腰。
on the streets, but it's also people running safe houses and things. They make their grand entrance at the end of June 1970. Now, Heath, Ted Heath has an unparalleled record, I think, in modern British history of making well-intentioned but disastrous political miscalculations. So his first one, this is the summer of 1970, are you going to ban the traditional unionist marches, the Orange Order marches and things? And he says, no, I'm not going to do that.
嗯，本能的反应，我想你会想，如果我对这不太了解，我就不会去干涉。我暂时采取不干涉态度。贝尔法斯特的一位英国官员说：“这是我有生以来见过的单一最大误判。”这可以说是相当大的断言了。实际上，他可能是对的，因为在6月27日星期六，贝尔法斯特举行了规模宏大的奥兰治秩序游行。不可避免的冲突和骚乱升级成了大规模的街头斗争和枪战。最激烈的战斗最终发生在一个叫短滩（Short Strand）的地方，那是东贝尔法斯特的一个天主教飞地。
Because I've just come in as prime minister. I don't want to alienate Protestant opinion in Northern Ireland. But also, you said he doesn't know anything about Northern Ireland. No, he doesn't. It's true. I mean, to be fair, his following advice. He did end up living in Salisbury, so I'm going to occasionally rally to his cause. Okay, we're going to stick up for Ted Heath.
那是圣马太教堂（Matthews Church）周围，一个天主教教堂。这也是临时派第一次进入故事的地方。有一小群人。他们装备了M1卡宾枪。他们驻扎在教堂周围。那是他们向保皇党投掷汽油弹和IUC（皇家阿尔斯特警察）猛烈开火的场景。大约30人受伤。3人死亡。其中两名是新教徒，一名是天主教徒。这不是动乱中最大的街头战役之一，但我认为这是最重要的战役之一，因为这是首次真正确立普罗沃斯（Provos）街头信誉的时刻。每个人都说他们回来了，你知道的。这些人将挺身而出对抗当局并保卫天主教地区等等。所以泰德·希斯犯了一个严重的错误。仅仅几天后，当局又犯了一个更严重的错误，给爱尔兰共和军送了一份更大的礼。所以7月3日星期五的傍晚，也就是这之后连一个星期都不到，英国装甲运兵车开进了贝尔法斯特下福尔斯（Lower Falls）地区，这是一个天主教工人阶级地区。他们进去是为了封锁一条特定的街道，
Yeah. Well, the instinctive thing, I suppose, you think, if I don't know much about this, I'm not going to intervene. I'll just be hands off for the time being. One British official in Belfast said, this was the greatest single miscalculation I've ever seen made in the course of my whole life, which is quite a big statement. And actually, he's probably right, because on Saturday, the 27th of June, there are a huge, Orange Order parades across Belfast. The inevitable fighting and rioting escalates into sort of massive street fighting and gun battles. And the fiercest fighting ends up being a place called the Short Strand, which is a Catholic enclave in East Belfast.
叫做巴尔干街（Balkan Street），这是一条砖砌的排屋窄街。他们接到线报称24号藏有正式派爱尔兰共和军的武器库。所以官方派爱尔兰共和军，汤姆，也就是马克思主义者、高领毛衣那些人。英国人进去找到了枪，但当他们从房子里出来时，外面聚集了非常愤怒的群众，人们开始摇晃装甲运兵车。然后人们开始扔石头、汽油弹之类东西。作为苏格兰卫队的士兵向人群发射催泪瓦斯，然后他们开始呼吁增援。接着，爱尔兰共和军的两翼都大举出现并开始开枪。所以这是一个非常混乱的场景。他们不是在互相射击
And it's a round of church, Matthews Church, Catholic Church. And this is where the provisionals first entered the story. There's a small group of them. They're armed with M1 carbines. They're positioned around the church. And there's the scene of them kind of blasting it. away at loyalist petrol bombers and the IUC. And about 30 people are injured. Three people are killed. Two of them Protestants, one of them Catholic. It's not one of the biggest street
。他们并肩作战。不，他们没有互相射击。不，我不会排除这种可能。所以这里有一场巨大的街头战役。有催泪瓦斯、钉子炸弹、汽油弹、狙击手，人们在建路障。双方发射了成百上千发弹药。当天晚上10点，英国驻北爱尔兰指挥官伊恩·弗里兰（Sir Ian Freeland）爵士说：“我要整个福尔斯地区被封锁，并将其置于无限期的宵禁之下，基本上是实施封锁。”所以现在你看到了这样的场景，已经是深夜10点，有直升机从该地区上空飞过，那里涌现出阵阵烟雾。直升机配有扩音器，扩音器里传出一个清晰的英国声音，告诉人们：“离开街道，否则格杀勿论。该地区现在处于宵禁状态。”所以这非常像《现代启示录》的场景，烟雾、催泪瓦斯、燃烧的火焰，还有直升机发出带有这种末日信息的喊话。在接下来的两天里，数千名英国士兵在直升机和装甲车的支持下，穿过了福尔斯地区。他们强行搜查房屋以寻找武器。他们挨家挨户地搜查。
battles of the troubles, but I would argue it's one of the most important because it's the moment that first really establishes the provost street cred. Everybody says they're back, you know. These are the people who are going to stand up to the authorities and defend, you know, Catholic areas and stuff. So Ted Heath's made one bad mistake. And just, days later, the authorities make an even bigger one which gives the IRA an even bigger gift. So on the late afternoon of Friday the 3rd of July, so this is what, not even a week later, British armoured personnel carriers move into the Lower Falls area of Belfast, kind of Catholic working class area. And they're going in to seal off one particular street
他们逮捕了300多人，并且确实找到了数百支枪支和炸弹、大量的弹药之类。但这给英国陆军带来了巨大的声誉打击，因为事后有很多关于士兵行为恶劣、砸毁人们房屋的故事。所以这是一位当地激进分子的说法：“神圣的雕像被砸碎在地上。全家福肖像和图片被砸碎。家具被撕裂和推翻。窗户被打破，门被卸下。一些被打的人仍然躺在那里，满身血迹和淤青。”
called Balkan Street, which is this kind of brick terraced narrow street. And they've been tipped off that there is an official IRA arms cash at number 24. So the official IRAs, Tom, the Marxists, the Poloneck people. And the British go in and they find the guns, but when they, as they come out of the house, there's this crowd outside, very angry, and people start rocking the armoured personnel carriers. And then people start throwing stones and petrol bombs and stuff. And the soldiers who are Scots guards, they fire tear gas at the crowds, and then they start calling for reinforcements. And then both wings of the IRA turn. up on mass and start shooting. So it's a very chaotic scene. And they're not kind of shooting
现在，军队事后表示，这一切都不是真的。这只是共和党的宣传。这是垃圾。英国男孩们的表现无可挑剔。但我对此不太确定。宵禁区内根本不允许任何记者进入。而且军队自己的日志显示，部队事先被指示要“具有攻击性”。
each other. They're fighting side by side. No, they're not shooting each other. No, I wouldn't put it past them. So there's this huge kind of street battle. There's tear gas, there are nail bombs, there are petrol bombs, there are snipers, the people building barricades. Both sides are firing hundreds and hundreds of rounds of ammunition. And at 10 o'clock that evening, the British commander in Northern Ireland, Sir Ian Freeland, he says, I want the whole. falls area sealed off and I want it put under indefinite curfew, basically put it under lockdown. And so you have this scene now, it's 10 o'clock at night and you have helicopters flying
我认为这些故事，你知道的，其中一些可能被夸大了，但显然其中包含事实的成分。我的意思是，承受压力的士兵在搜查人们的房子时，他们真的会把脚在地毯上擦干净吗？我不这么认为。所以大概那些房子被搜查的人，不再给他们端茶倒水或做类似的事情了？不，不，不。
over the area from which there are kind of clouds of smoke emerging. And the helicopters have loud speakers and from the loudspeakers, a kind of clipped British voice is telling people, get off the streets or you will be shot. This area is now under curfew. So it's very like, you know, sort of apocalypse now seen, smoke, tear gas, burning fires and helicopters with this voice coming out with this apocalyptic message. And then for the next two days, thousands of British soldiers, supported by helicopters, supported by armoured cars, move through the falls area. They are for forcibly searching the houses for weapons. They go through house after house.
浓烟从该地区不断冒出。直升机上装有扩音器，扩音器里传出一个生硬的英式声音，在告诉人们离开街道，否则将被枪击。该地区现在实施宵禁。这非常像那种现代启示录的场景，有烟雾、催泪瓦斯、熊熊烈火，还有直升机播放着末日般的警告信息。在接下来的两天里，数千名英国士兵在直升机和装甲车的支援下，推进到了福尔斯地区。他们强行搜查房屋以寻找武器。他们挨家挨户地搜查。
They arrest more than 300 people. and they actually find hundreds of guns and bombs, loads of ammunition and stuff like that. But this is a terrible reputational blow to the British Army because there are afterwards tons of stories about the soldiers behaving badly and wrecking people's houses. So this is one local activist. Holy statues were smashed on the floor. Family portraits and pictures were smashed. Fit furniture was ripped and overturned. Windows were broken and doors off the hinges. some of the people who'd been beaten were still lying there, bloody and bruised.
他们逮捕了300多人，并且真的查获了数百支枪支和炸弹、大量弹药之类统统都有。但这对英国军队的声誉是一个沉重的打击，因为事后流传着大量关于士兵行为不端、毁坏人们房屋的故事。因此，有一位当地活动人士说：神圣的雕像被砸碎在地上。家庭肖像和画作被砸毁。家具被撕裂并推翻。窗户被打破，门被卸下合页。一些被打的人仍然躺在那里，浑身是血，伤痕累累。
Now, the army said afterwards, this is all untrue. This is just Republican propaganda. This is rubbish. British boys behaved impeccably. But I'm not sure about that. No journalists were allowed in the curfew zone at all. And the army's own log sheets show that the troops were instructed beforehand to, quote, be aggressive.
后来军方表示，这一切都不是真的。这只是共和党人的宣传。这是无稽之谈。英国小伙子们的表现无可挑剔。但我对此并不确定。根本没有记者被允许进入宵禁区。而且军队自己的日志记录显示，部队事先曾奉命“采取强硬态度”。
I think these stories, you know, some of them might be exaggerated, but there's clearly an element of truth in it. I mean, soldiers under pressure searching people's houses, are they really going to wipe their feet on the door mat? I don't think so. So presumably the people whose houses are being searched, they're not giving them cups of tea anymore or anything like that. No, no, no.
我认为这些故事，你知道的，其中一些可能被夸大了，但其中显然包含真实成分。我的意思是，士兵们在压力下搜查人们的房屋，他们真的会把脚在地垫上擦干净吗？我不这么认为。所以可以想象，那些房屋被搜查的人们，他们不会再给士兵们倒茶或做类似的事情了。不，不，不。
So you're dead right. When they arrived in 1969, it was fish and chips and cups of tea. But right now, from this point, you know, Catholic housewives will spit in the soldiers' faces, kids throw stones at them. And the provisional IRA have been watching all this with delight. because basically they know that it's turned to the local community against the army, and they're going to get a flood of recruits, which they do. So we're only a couple of weeks into Ted Heath's premiership.
你说得完全没错。1969年他们刚到的时候，只有炸鱼薯条和一杯杯茶。但现在，从这个节点开始，你知道的，天主教家庭主妇会往士兵脸上吐口水，孩子们向他们扔石头。临时派爱尔共和国军一直兴高采烈地关注着这一切。因为基本上他们知道，这已经把当地社区推向了军队的对立面，他们将迎来一波新兵入伍潮，事实也确实如此。所以当时距离希思出任首相才仅仅过了几个星期。
I mean, this has all happened very quickly, and it's taken a very, very dark turn. And a few days after this, our old friend Sir Burke Trend is back, and he discusses this with Heath and Heath's Home Secretary, Reginald Mordling. We shall be talking about Reginald Mordling later on. Great character, exactly. and they agree, listen, if things continue to deteriorate at this rate, we are going to have to suspend the Parliament of Northern Ireland, and we're going to have to send in a British team to run Northern Ireland ourselves. But they do not want to do that.
我的意思是，这一切发生得非常快，而且情况急转直下，变得非常非常黑暗。几天之后，我们的老朋友伯克·特伦德爵士回来了，他与希思以及希思的内政大臣雷金纳德·莫德林讨论了此事。我们稍后会聊到雷金纳德·莫德林。真是个了不起的人物，一点没错。他们一致认为，听着，如果局势照这个速度继续恶化下去，我们将不得不暂停北爱尔兰议会，我们不得不派出一支英国团队亲自管理北爱尔兰。但他们并不想这么做。
They absolutely do not want to do that. No, they don't. So that would be the nuclear option to abolish Stormont and introduce direct rule. But he doesn't want to do that. He's only been Prime Minister three weeks. He wants to give the Northern Ireland Prime Minister James Chichester Clark a chance to sort this out. And remember from last time, James Chichester Clark, I mean, this is going to sound very harsh. I hope his descendants don't listen.
他们绝对不想这么做。不，他们不想。所以这将是终极手段，也就是废除斯托蒙特并实行直接统治。但他不想这么做。他担任首相才区区三周。他想给北爱尔兰首相詹姆斯·奇切斯特-克拉克一个机会来解决这个问题。大家还记得上次提到的詹姆斯·奇切斯特-克拉克吧，我的意思是，这话听起来可能很苛刻。希望他的后代不要听到。
I think he was useless. He's from the landed gentry. He's a farmer. He's kind of very slow and plodding and unimaginative. Of course, he's trapped between the nationalists on the one hand and the kind of Paisley-Hardliners on the other. But he doesn't have any of the political skills to deal with it. I said that also at this meeting is Heath's Home Secretary Reginald Mordling. and we should talk about him a little bit.
我觉得他简直一无是处。他出身于地主乡绅阶层。他是个农民。他的作风非常缓慢、沉重且缺乏想象力。当然，他一方面夹在民族主义者中间，另一方面又夹在帕斯里强硬派中间。但他完全不具备处理这些问题的政治技巧。我还说过，出席这次会议的还有希思的内政大臣雷金纳德·莫德林，我们应该多聊聊他。
There is possibly a case that the British might have handled Northern Ireland more sensitivity in the early 70s with a different Home Secretary because Reginald Mordling, who I actually really like, is a truly terrible person to be in charge of the Home Office. So to explain to people who he was, he'd been the runner-up to Ted Heath in the Tory leadership. You should approve of him, Tom, because he had a first in classics from Oxford and he'd been in RAF intelligence during the war. And he's suave, he's witty, he's very liberal-minded for a Tory, he's very clever, he's incredibly affable.
有一种看法认为，如果在70年代初换一个不同的内政大臣，英国人处理北爱尔兰问题可能会更温和一些，因为雷金纳德·莫德林——我其实挺喜欢他的——作为一个掌管内政部的人来说，实在是个极其糟糕的人选。向大家介绍一下他的背景，他曾在保守党党魁选举中输给泰德·希思，屈居第二。汤姆，你应该赞赏他，因为他拥有牛津大学古典学一级荣誉学位，并在战争期间加入过英国皇家空军情报部门。他温文尔雅，机智风趣，作为保守党人思想非常开明，极为聪明，而且极其平易近人。
On the other hand, he is luscious, he is incredibly lazy, he is greedy and he is fantastically corrupt. And he's also a massive, massive boozer. So if I tell you his daily intake, you would have brandy for breakfast, gin at mid-morning, and then at lunch he'd have wine and digestif. And then for the rest of the day, he'd just be as the mood took him. I mean, he'd be asleep, actually, for the last of the day. And Reginald Mordling, he's basically one of those people. He's the ultimate sort of 70s British politician, massive glasses.
另一方面，他很贪图享乐，懒惰至极，贪婪成性，并且腐败透顶。他还是个超级无敌的大酒鬼。如果我告诉你他一天的饮酒量，你就会知道他早餐要喝白兰地，上午加餐时要喝金酒，午餐时则要喝葡萄酒和餐后酒。而在接下来的时间里，他就会随性而为。我的意思是，事实上他一天里剩下的时间都在睡觉。而雷金纳德·莫德林，他基本上就是那种人。他可以说是70年代英国政客的典型代表，戴着一副硕大的眼镜。
He's quite overweight. He's flecked with Dandruff and he's stinking of gin. And he absolutely despises Northern Ireland, and he's not afraid to show it. So when he made his first trip to Northern Ireland, which was just before the Falls Curfew, he made it absolutely obvious to everybody that he didn't want to be there and he was incredibly bored. And even the British military commander said afterwards, he seems, and I quote, completely ignorant. And when his play took off, he infamously, as soon as it took off and he knew he was off northern Irish soil, he said very loudly, for God's sake, bring me a large scotch.
他身体相当发福。身上沾满头皮屑，浑身散发着金酒的气味。他极其厌恶北爱尔兰，而且毫不掩饰这一点。因此，当他首次前往北爱尔兰访问——那正是在福尔斯宵禁前夕——他向所有人极其明确地表现出他根本不想去那里，并且觉得无聊透顶。甚至连英国军事指挥官事后都说，他看起来，我引用一下，“完全无知”。当他的飞机起飞时，据传他臭名昭著地在飞机刚起飞、确认已经离开北爱尔兰领土后，非常大声地说：“看在上帝的份上，给我来大杯苏格兰威士忌。”
What a bloody awful country. So anyway, the story of the next nine months is these men, Heath, mordling, Chichester Clark, basically totally out of their depth, dithering and dallying while the situation gets steadily worse. So a good example of how it's getting worse in a small way. You mentioned the cups of tea. There had been a lot of fraternisation between the army and the locals at the end of 1969. The army had even organised kind of clubs for local kids, trips and stuff for them. They'd organised a New Year's Eve, disdeme, disdeme.
这鬼地方真他妈糟透了。总之，接下来九个月的故事就是，这些人——希思、莫德林、奇切斯特-克拉克——基本上完全无法应对局面，在局势不断恶化的同时优柔寡断、拖延磨蹭。所以，这是一个关于局势如何一点点恶化的好例子。你刚才提到了茶杯。在1969年底，军队和当地人之间曾有过很多联谊。军队甚至为当地儿童组织过各种俱乐部、郊游之类的活动。他们还组织了一个除夕夜舞会……舞会。
with local girls in dairy. But a year on, things are completely different. Girls who now fraternise with British soldiers are punished for it. There's a soldier in Peter Taylor's book about the army in Northern Ireland, Brits, it's called. Brilliant book. A soldier tells him about finding a girl tied to a lamp post and she had literally been, her head had been shaved and she'd literally been tared and feathered. He said the tar ran down her neck in the front of her breast and her hands were badly affected
与德里的当地姑娘们一起。但一年过去后，情况完全变了。现在凡是与英国士兵交往的姑娘都会受到惩罚。彼得·泰勒写过一本关于英国军队在北爱尔兰的书，书名叫《英国人》，这是一本极其精彩的书。书中一个士兵向他讲述，他发现一个女孩被绑在路灯柱上，字面意思上，她的头发被剃光了，而且浑身被涂满了柏油和羽毛。他说柏油顺着她的脖子流到胸前，她的双手也受到了严重伤害，
where she'd been clawing at her face to get it off and the feathers were stuck to the tar. We had to cut her away from the lamppost and take it to hospital. So this is the sort of context. And then in February 1971, trouble breaks out in an area of North Belfast called the New Lodge area.
因为她曾绝望地用手抓挠面部试图将其扯掉，羽毛都粘在了柏油上。我们不得不把她从灯柱上解救下来并送到医院。这就是当时的背景。接着在1971年2月，北贝尔法斯特一个名为新洛奇的地区爆发了冲突。
And this is a Catholic area. It's very densely populated. And the Army believed that the provisional have been stockpiling guns on the estate and have been launching search missions. There are days of clashes and these escalates on the evening of the 5th of February. into street fighting, the army sent in a unit of Royal Artillery.
这是一个天主教聚居区。人口非常稠密。军队认为临时派一直在该地产囤积枪支，并展开了搜查行动。冲突持续了好几天，并在2月5日晚演变成街头武斗，军队派出了一个皇家炮兵单位。
They get there, it's chaotic scene, bricks, petrol bombs, bottles, all of this. And then as one soldier described it, it's like the crowd parts, like the sort of parting of the Red Sea. As he describes it, this chap just popped out with the machine gun and opened up. And this chap is Billy Reed of the Provisional IRA. He's got a sterling submachine gun. He shoots four soldiers wounded, and he shoots Gunner Robert Curtis through the heart. And Curtis becomes the first British soldier to die in Northern Ireland. He was from Newcastle.
他们到达时，现场一片混乱，砖块、燃烧弹、酒瓶，应有尽有。正如一个士兵所描述的那样，人群突然裂开，就像红海分开一样。据他描述，这个家伙突然拿着机枪跳出来并开火了。这个人就是临时派爱尔共和国军的比利·里德。他拿着一把司登冲枪。他击伤了四名士兵，并一枪击中了炮兵罗伯特·柯蒂斯的胸口。柯蒂斯成为了第一个在北爱尔兰阵亡的英国士兵。他来自纽卡斯尔。
He was 20 years old. He left a pregnant wife who was also 20. An interview by the press afterwards, his father said, I have no idea what my son died for. And his widow, his wife, said, Our boys should be brought home immediately. We should leave the mobs to fight it out. among themselves.
他年仅20岁。他留下了同样20岁且身怀有孕的妻子。事后在接受媒体采访时，他的父亲说：“我根本不知道我儿子是为了什么而死。”而他的遗孀、他的妻子则说：“我们的男孩应该立刻被接回家。我们应该让那些暴徒自己去自相残杀。”
Now, already at this point, a lot of people in Britain agree with this. So if you look at the polls, in 1969, most people had favoured the decision to introduce troops, but even in early, you know, the early 1970s, so 70, 71, more than half of the electorate think that the troops should be brought home and Northern Ireland should just be abandoned. And this is what the government is kind of contending with all through this story. But Heath's cabinet have absolutely no intention of pulling out. out. So if you look at the Cabinet minutes after this, they've lost their first, you know, British Army casualty. And the Cabinet minutes say, they know, and I quote, many people would
现在，此时此刻，英国国内已经有很多人持这种观点了。如果你看一下民意调查，在1969年，大多数人还赞成派兵的决定；但即使到了早期，你知道的，70年代初，也就是1970年、1971年，超过一半的选民认为应该把部队撤回来，北爱尔兰应该直接被放弃。这就是整个事件中政府一直在努力应对的局面。但希思的内阁绝对没有撤军的打算。因此，如果你看看此后的内阁会议记录，他们已经失去了第一个英国陆军阵亡人员。内阁会议记录显示，他们知道，我引用一下，许多人会
favor abandoning the province to its fate, a course which the government could not contemplate. And the reason they couldn't contemplate is they say international opinion would damn us for it. I mean, Ted Kennedy wouldn't, but a lot of other people would. And the result would be the sectarian bloodbath. And they agree a common line. And they say, this is not. It's not just about communal strife. It's not about rebellion against political injustice. This is the outcome of deliberate terrorism by the IRA. Now, through this story, we have been quite down on British government policy,
主张将该省抛弃任其自生自灭，而这是政府绝对无法考虑的做法。他们无法考虑的原因是，他们说国际舆论会因此唾弃我们。我的意思是，泰德·肯尼迪可能不会，但很多其他人会。其结果将是一场宗派血腥大屠杀。他们达成了一个共同的立场。他们说，这不仅仅是，这不仅仅是社群冲突。这不仅仅是针对政治不公的反叛。这是爱尔兰共和军蓄意恐怖主义的结果。在讲述这个故事的过程中，我们对英国政府的政策一直持相当批判的态度，
and we will probably continue to be, because Heath goes on to make some absolutely cataclysmic mistakes. But I think it is actually worth stopping, just to say for a moment that he's not entirely wrong about this. So the conflict obviously has deep roots, and among the causes, undoubtedly, are British government neglect and incompetence and, of course, the discriminatory nature of the storm on state. But just on the British side, Heath's intentions, I think, are pretty admirable. Heath wants to see a reformed, non-sectarian, Northern Irish state that does not discriminate. everybody's treated equally and nobody gets shot.
而且我们很可能会继续这样下去，因为希思接下来犯下了一些绝对是灾难性的错误。但我认为实际上值得停下来思考一下，只需花片刻时间说明，他在这一点上并非完全错误。冲突的根源显然很深，其中的原因无疑包括英国政府的忽视和无能，当然还有斯托蒙特政权的歧视性质。但单就英国方面而言，希思的意图我认为是相当令人钦佩的。希思希望看到一个改革后的、非宗派的、不搞歧视的北爱尔兰国家。每个人都受到平等对待，没有人被枪杀。
And actually he's open to all kinds of different things. He's open to links with Dublin. He's open to rethinking Northern Ireland's constitutional status. He will consider anything. And historians who've written about this almost uniformly say, the Heath government is much more open-minded when it comes to Northern Ireland than any previous British government had ever been. Now, as for the army, the army made terrible mistakes
事实上，他对各种不同的可能性都持开放态度。他愿意与都柏林建立联系。他愿意重新思考北爱尔兰的宪法地位。他会考虑任何事情。研究过这段历史的历史学家几乎一致认为，与以往任何一届英国政府相比，希思政府在北爱尔兰问题上要开明得多。至于军队，军队犯下了可怕的错误，
and we'll be talking about one in particular next time. And the army, of course, have all kinds of prejudices and blind spots and preconceptions and whatnot. Worth saying about the army in Northern Ireland, I mean, the army do not go in to kill people. I mean, they are trained killers, but they've been sent as peacekeepers. And the army, deep down, would love to go home. I mean, no one likes being sent to Northern Ireland. There are, however, people in this series of whom that's not actually true. They do want to kill people.
我们下次会专门讨论其中一个。当然，军队也有各种各样的偏见、盲点、先入之见等等。关于驻北爱尔兰的军队，值得一提的是，军队去那里并不是为了杀人。我的意思是，他们是受过训练的杀手，但他们是被派去充当维和人员的。而且军队内心深处非常渴望回家。我的意思是，没有人喜欢被派往北爱尔兰。然而，在这个系列中确实有些人并非如此。他们确实想杀人。
So we saw some in the first episode, the Ulster Volunteer Force, the people who go out from pubs, and carry out sectarian murders. The provisional IRA. They actively want to increase the tension. They haven't imported guns just to exhibit them on their walls. They've imported guns to use them. They actually do want to kill people. And the reason they want to kill people is not necessarily because they're in averted
所以在第一集里我们看到了一些人，阿尔斯特志愿军，那些从酒吧里出来并实施宗派谋杀的人。临时派爱尔兰共和军。他们积极地想要加剧紧张局势。他们进口枪支可不是为了在墙上当装饰品展示的。他们进口枪支是为了使用它们。他们确实想杀人。而他们想杀人的原因，不一定是因为他们是某种意义上的怪物，
comments monsters. It's because they think it is politically right to do so. We will get what we want. And I think that is a big difference between them and Ted Heath. I mean, Ted Heath doesn't want to kill anybody. people do get killed, but I mean, it's not necessarily what he wanted. I mean, he had been at the Nuremberg rally, hadn't he? He'd fought in the Second World War, so he is aware of how deep hatreds can run.
而是因为他们认为这样做在政治上是正确的。我们会得到我们想要的。我认为这是他们与泰德·希思之间的一个巨大区别。我的意思是，泰德·希思并不想杀任何人。虽然确实有人被杀，但我的意思是，这不一定是他想要的。我的意思是，他曾去过纽伦堡集会，不是吗？他参加过第二次世界大战，所以他很清楚仇恨能有多深。
Yeah. But even so, in this, there does seem a failure of imagination on his part to contemplate, I guess that within the United Kingdom, there could be hatred so violent that there are substantial parts of different populations. Yeah. They want to pull the whole house down. That's the problem, isn't it? Because once you reach that stage with people,
是的。即便如此，在这件事上，他似乎缺乏一种想象力，无法去设想——我猜——在联合王国内部，竟然会存在如此暴烈的仇恨，以至于不同族群中存在着相当庞大的群体……是的。他们想把整个房子都拆毁。这才是问题所在，不是吗？因为一旦你和这样的人走到这一步，
there's no negotiations really that can solve it. Well, we're actually, I mean, you're right to make that point about negotiations because you're anticipating what we'll talk about in the next episode. When they do have negotiations, they have negotiations with the IRA. And it turns out that the IRA basically say,
那就真的没有任何谈判能够解决问题了。嗯，实际上，我的意思是，你提出关于谈判的那一点是正确的，因为你提前预示了我们将在下一集里讨论的内容。当他们进行谈判时，他们是与爱尔兰共和军进行谈判。结果发现，爱尔兰共和军基本上会说，
well, actually, we'd prefer to carry on fighting and killing than, you know, we'd rather not do a deal, actually. Yeah. So back to the story, the early months of 1971. If anybody thinks that Gunner Curtis's death will bring an end, they've got a shock coming. Because four days after that, five BBC engineers are killed by a landmine and County Toron, planted by the IRA meant for an army patrol. A week later, a second soldier, John Lorry, he was 22, is killed by the IRA,
好吧，其实我们宁愿继续战斗和杀戮，你知道的，我们其实宁愿不做这笔交易。好吧。回到故事本身，1971年的头几个月。如果有人认为柯蒂斯炮兵的死会带来终结，那他们可要大吃一惊了。因为在那之后的第四天，五名BBC工程师在蒂龙郡被爱尔兰共和军埋设的地雷炸死，本来这个地雷是为一支军队巡逻队准备的。一周后，第二名士兵约翰·洛里——他年仅22岁——被爱尔兰共和军杀害，
and then two RUC men, two policemen in the Ardoin are killed by IRA snipers. And then you have the event that I think shocks people in Britain more than any other. A massive story in March 1971. So it's Wednesday the 10th of March. There were three young men from the Royal Highland Fusiliers and they'd gone out to have a drink. As soldiers were allowed to do in those days, they were allowed to go out in civilian clothes to have a pint. And they went to Mooney's Bar in the city centre. and they were Dougal McCohey, who was 23,
接着，阿尔多因的两名皇家阿尔斯特警察局警察被爱尔兰共和军狙击手杀害。然后就发生了那件我认为比其他任何事情都更震撼英国民众的事件。1971年3月发生了一起轰动的大事件。那是3月10日星期三。有三名来自皇家高地轻步兵团的年轻士兵外出喝酒。当时士兵被允许这样做，他们被允许穿便服出去喝一品脱啤酒。他们去了市中心的穆尼酒吧，他们是23岁的
and two brothers, John and Joseph McCake, who were 17 and 18. I mean, the ages of the people in this story, they're so young, a lot of them. I mean, they're basically the age of schoolchildren, some of them. So they're off duty, they're in civilian clothes, and they're in this pub, and a bloke comes up to them, and he says, oh, you British Army soldiers, I'm actually a former soldier. Let me buy you some drinks, and he buys them some drinks, and they get chatt. in their chat for a bit. And then as bloke says,
道格拉斯·麦考伊，以及17岁和18岁的两兄弟约翰和约瑟夫·麦凯。我的意思是，这个故事里的人们的年龄，他们太年轻了，其中许多人。我的意思是，他们基本上就是学龄儿童的年纪，有些人是这样的。所以他们当时正在休假，穿着便服，在这个酒吧里，有个家伙朝他们走过来，他说：“哦，你们是英国陆军士兵吗？其实我以前也是个士兵。我请你们喝一杯吧。”于是他给他们买了几杯酒，他们便聊了起来。他们聊了一会儿。接着那个家伙说，
oh, do you want to come to a party? There's a party, all the rest of it. And they go off. They're due back at their barracks at about 6.30. They don't show up. That's not uncommon because, you know, it wasn't unknown for soldiers to go out, have a few pints, lose track of time,
“你们想去参加派对吗？有个派对，还有别的什么的。”然后他们就一起离开了。他们本应在6点30分左右回到军营。但他们没有出现。这其实并不罕见，因为，你知道的，士兵们外出喝几杯啤酒、忘了时间，
you know, start talking to some girls or whatever, and then they come back late. They get into trouble, of course, but it's not unusual. But a few hours later, some children were playing in fields at a place called White Bray, which was north of Belfast.
你知道的，跟一些姑娘聊天什么的，然后很晚才回去，这种事并不是没有发生过。他们当然会惹上麻烦，但这并不罕见。然而几个小时后，一些小孩子在贝尔法斯特北部一个叫怀特布雷的地方的田野里玩耍，
and they saw something in a field, they saw a sort of pile of something in a field, they went over the children, and it was the bodies of these three Highlanders, and they'd been shot, all of them in the back of the head. And more than any other incident, this really cuts through, because they have, of course, been shot by the IRA.
他们在田野里看到了某种东西，看到田野里有一堆东西，孩子们便走了过去，结果发现那是这三名高地轻步兵的尸体，他们都被枪杀了，每个人的后脑勺都中了一枪。比以往任何其他事件都更甚的是，这起事件真正产生了深远的影响，因为他们显然是被爱尔兰共和军枪杀的。
One Belfast paper said, after all the horrors of recent weeks and months, Ulster people have almost lost the capacity for feeling shock, but the ruthless murder of three defenceless young soldiers, has cut to the quick. And in Britain, and there's a memoir by a paratrooper called Harry McCallion, who was a working class Catholic from Scotland. And he was stationed in Britain.
一家贝尔法斯特报纸写道：“在经历了几周和几个月的所有恐怖事件之后，阿尔斯特人几乎已经失去了感到震惊的能力，但对三名手无寸铁的年轻士兵的残酷谋杀，却深深刺痛了人们的心。”而在英国，有一个名为哈里·麦考利恩的伞兵的回忆录，他是一个来自苏格兰的工人阶级天主教徒。他当时驻扎在英国。
He writes in his memoir of the silence that fell over his kind of barracks when he and his comrades heard about these killings. And he writes, I looked at the faces of the older soldiers around me. I read on them the same thing. Just wait until we get across. For me and for everybody at the table, that was the major turning point. And so the risk is that the British Army is also starting to be radicalised, I suppose.
他在回忆录中写到了当他和战友们听到这些杀戮消息时，军营里陷入的那种死一般的寂静。他写道：“我看着身边老兵们的脸。我在他们脸上看到了同样的东西。‘等着吧，等我们过去。’对我以及桌上的每个人来说，那是主要的转折点。”所以危险在于，英国军队也开始走向激进化，我想是这样的。
And that must, I guess, then be a factor in British governmental calculations. So who knows what will happen? Will the British government consider pulling out or will they double down a critical moment, Dominic? And we will find out what the British government decides after the break. This episode is brought to you by Amazon. Tom throughout history, change has often been driven by businesses and institutions that end up having a massive impact on society as a whole. And there's probably no better example than the Ford Motor Company. Henry Ford and his managers revolutionized production through their pioneering assembly lines.
我想，这必须成为英国政府权衡时局的一个因素。所以谁知道会发生什么呢？英国政府会考虑撤军，还是会在关键时刻加倍下注呢，多米尼克？中场休息后，我们将为您揭晓英国政府的决定。本集节目由亚马逊赞助播出。汤姆，纵观历史，变革往往是由最终对整个社会产生巨大影响的企业和机构推动的。或许没有比福特汽车公司更好的例子了。亨利·福特和他的管理人员通过开创性的装配线彻底革新了生产方式。
And they influenced factories and working practices in countries all over them. the world. Another example of a business driving technological and social change is Amazon, which is increasing the number of its electric vehicles used for deliveries in Europe to over 10,000 by the end of this year, 2026. Now on top of that, over 50% of Amazon deliveries now come with less packaging or sometimes no added packaging at all. It helps to avoid unnecessary waste and it makes recycling at home that much easier. Find out more at amazon.com.uk U.K. slash sustainability. Hello, Camaradas. It's Dominic here. Sorry to interrupt the episode, but I just thought you'd
他们影响了世界各地国家的工厂和工作实践。另一个推动技术和社会变革的企业的例子是亚马逊，该公司正在增加其在欧洲用于配送的电动汽车数量，到今年（2026年）年底将超过10,000辆。不仅如此，如今超过50%的亚马逊快递都采用更少的包装，有时甚至完全没有添加包装。这有助于避免不必要的浪费，并让在家回收变得更加容易。请访问 amazon.com.uk/sustainability 了解更多信息。大家好，同志们。我是多米尼克。抱歉打扰本集节目，但我只是想让你们知道，我们一直在考虑你们经常写信给我们的一件事，这也是自从我们开播《历史的其余部分》（The Rest is History）以来被请求最多的主题之一，那就是西班牙内战。
like to know that we've been thinking about something that you've been writing to us a lot, one of the most requested subjects ever since we started the rest of its history, which is the Spanish Civil War. Now, I can tell you, that plans are afoot for us to do the Spanish Civil War at some point, hopefully next year in 2007. But as a little taster or teaser on our sister show, The Book Club, my co-presenter, Tabby and I have just released an episode on perhaps the emblematic novel of the Spanish Civil War, which is Ernest Hemingway's book, for whom the bell tolls. So in this episode, we do dig into the history. We talk about the clash between fascism and idealism. We talk about the roots of the
现在我可以告诉你们，我们正在计划在某个时候开展关于西班牙内战的内容，希望是在明年2007年。但在我们的姊妹节目《读书俱乐部》（The Book Club）中，作为一个小小的尝鲜或预告，我和我的联合主持人塔比刚刚发布了一集节目，探讨的或许是西班牙内战中最具象征意义的小说，也就是欧内斯特·海明威的书——《战地钟声》（For Whom the Bell Tolls）。所以在这一集中，我们深入探讨了历史。我们讨论了法西斯主义与理想主义之间的冲突，讨论了这场冲突的根源，当然还有它如何吸引了如此多的外国知识分子、艺术家和作家。海明威当然也是其中之一。你们中的许多人都会知道，海明威在战争期间身在西班牙。他是马德里的战地记者，当时马德里正遭到弗朗哥军队的围困。他在《战地钟声》中汲取了那段经历，讲述了一个美国志愿者的故事，他是一个游击队成员，正在与弗朗哥的军队作战。因此，如果您在本集节目结束时继续收听，我们将为您奉上一段独家短片，探讨西班牙内战的历史。大家好，欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》。
conflict and of course the way in which it drew in so many foreign intellectuals and artists and writers. Hemingway, of course, among them. And many of you will know that Hemingway was in Spain during the war. He was a correspondent in Madrid, which was under siege by Franco's forces. And he draws on that experience in for whom the bell tolls to tell the story of an American volunteer who's part of a guerrilla unit who are fighting Franco's troops. So if you keep Listening at the end of this episode, we will have an exclusive short clip which discusses the history of the Spanish Civil War. Hello everyone and welcome back to the rest is history.
那是1971年3月。三名年轻的苏格兰高地轻步兵团士兵被谋杀，随之而来的是，贝尔法斯特街头以及我猜还有军队军营里的气氛变得比以往任何时候都要黑暗。所以，你在中场休息前描述了军队的恐怖和报纸的谴责。但那并不是一种普遍的看法，对吧？因为北爱尔兰内部显然有一些势力。我猜爱尔兰更广泛的范围内也有人认为，在爱恨情仇和战争中，一切都是公平的。他们罪有应得。
It is March 1971. Three young Highland Fusiliers have been murdered and with that the mood on the streets of Belfast and in the army barracks as well, I guess, is darker than it's ever been. So you, before the break, described the horror of the army and the condemnation of the newspapers. But that's not a kind of universal perspective, is it? Because there are obviously elements within Northern Ireland. And I would guess Ireland more generally who think, well, all's fair in love and war. They had it coming.
是的。事实上，有一本关于70年代北爱尔兰的精彩书籍，名叫《看门》（Watching the Door），作者是一位爱尔兰专栏作家，一个相当有争议的爱尔兰专栏作家凯文·迈尔斯（Kevin Myers），他出生在莱斯特，但父母是爱尔兰天主教徒。当时他正在爱尔兰电视台RTE担任记者。他在书中回忆说，当这三个人被杀害时，在他的共和党人联系人中，有一种“暗自满意”的情绪，引述他们的原话。人们会对他说，你知道的，他们属于英国军队。我的意思是，他们很年轻，但他们是英军士兵。所以他们是咎由自取。有一次，他的司机（一个天主教徒）对他说，战争要来了，而且会很
Yeah. So there's a wonderful book actually about Northern Ireland in the 70s called Watching the Door by an Irish columnist, quite controversial Irish. columnist actually, Kevin Myers, who was born in Leicester, but he was from Irish Catholic parents. At the time, he was working as a journalist for RTE, the Irish TV service. And he remembers in this book that when these three guys were killed, among his Republican contacts, there was a mood of, quote, quiet satisfaction. People would say to him, well, you know, they belong to the British Army. I mean, they were very young, but they were British Army soldiers. So they had what was coming to them. And at one point his driver, who's a Catholic, says to him, the war is coming and it's going to be
严重。临时派（Provis）有从美国运来的新鲜装备。这个镇上将会有从未他妈死过的人死去。这听起来很戏剧化，但实际上我认为在这一点上，很多人真的认为将会爆发一场内战。我的意思是，记住，汤姆，有很多人还活着，他们还记得20世纪20年代的暴力事件。是的。你知道，那只是50年前的事。所以那些在20年代可能20岁的人现在已经70岁了，能够向他们的孩子和孙子讲述这件事，而且可能已经讲了很多年了。有些民族主义者在北爱尔兰从未感到安全。有些统一派一直认为天主教徒是一种所谓的第五纵队，而爱尔兰共和军正准备袭击他们。
serious. The provis have fresh gear coming from America. There will be people dying in this town who have never effing died before. And that sounds very melodramatic, but actually I think at this point a lot of people genuinely thinking there's going to be a civil war. I mean, remember there are a lot of people alive, Tom, who remember the violence of the 1920s. Yeah. You know, it's only 50 years before. So there'll be people who might have been 20 in the 1920s are now 70 and are able to tell their children and grandchildren about it and probably have done for years. There are nationalists who've never felt safe in Northern Ireland. There are unionists who have always believed that the Catholics are a kind of fifth column and the IRA were poised to attack them.
我认为对于这两群人来说，他们都会说，好吧，就是这样。就是这样。决定性的摊牌就在眼前。正因如此，1971年才会出现民间自卫组织的巨大增长。因此，在贝尔法斯特的工人阶级新教徒社区，人们一直在建立这些所谓的保皇党防卫协会（loyalist defense associations）。其中最大的是阿尔斯特防卫协会（Ulster Defense Association，简称UDA），这同样是70、80、90年代一个让人浮想联翩的缩写。这是保皇党自卫组织的一个联盟。它成立于1971年秋天。在其鼎盛时期，它拥有2.5万到4万名关联会员，这非常惊人。它甚至还有女子部队。在北爱尔兰冲突期间，UDA制造了400多起谋杀案，
And I think for both of these groups, they say, well, this is it. This is it. The decisive showdown is at hand. And it's for this reason. you have this huge growth in 1971 of vigilante groups. So in Belfast working class Protestant areas, people have been setting up these loyalist defense associations, as they're called. And the biggest is the Ulster Defense Association, the UDA, again, a sort of acronym to conjure with in the 70s, 80s, 90s. This was this alliance of loyalist vigilantes. It was set up in the autumn of 1971. At its peak, it had somewhere between 25 and 40,000 associated members, extraordinary. It had women's units. In the course of the troubles, the UDA was responsible for more than 400 murders,
其中几乎全部都是天主教平民。这与爱尔兰共和军的杀戮率相比如何？哦，高得多。在冲突期间，爱尔兰共和军是迄今为止最大的杀手。我的意思是，这其实很有趣。现在我要说的是，得到最多关注、最多报纸版面的杀手肯定是英军。但从数字上看，迄今为止最大的杀手是临时派爱尔兰共和军。不过，我们还是回到保皇党身上。这是一个有趣的问题：人们是如何向自己解释这一点的呢？
so almost all of them, Catholic civilians. How does that compare with the IRA's killing rate? Oh, far more. The IRA is by far the biggest killer in the course of the troubles. I mean, it's interesting, actually. The killers that get most attention, I would say, at most newsprint, certainly now are the British Army. But by far numerically the biggest killers are the provisional IRA. Back though to the loyalists. Interesting question. How do people justify this to themselves?
你知道是什么促使你加入保皇党自卫组织的？嗯，彼得·泰勒（Peter Taylor）在他的书《保皇党》（Loyalists）中举了一个名叫马丁·斯诺登（Martin Snodden）的人的例子。网上有很多对这家伙的采访，因为他现在是一位相当著名的和平活动家。马丁·斯诺登在天主教徒占多数的西贝尔法斯特的一个新教徒飞地长大。因此，他和他的家人在60年代末感到非常害怕。他们感到四面楚歌、深陷重围。当然，随着紧张局势不断升温，情况变得更糟了。当他在1970年16岁时，他加入了阿尔斯特志愿军（UVF）。
You know, what would make you join a loyalist vigilante group? Well, in his book, Loyalists, Peter Taylor gives the example of one man called Martin Snotten. And there's lots of interviews to this guy online because he's quite a prominent peace campaigner now. Martin Snodden grew up in a Protestant enclave in Catholic West Belfast. So he and his family in the late 60s felt very fearful. They felt embattled, surrounded. And then of course things got worse the more that the sort of temperature dropped. And when he was 16 years old in 1970, he joined the UVF.
在他看来，保卫家人是顺理成章的事。你知道，这是勇敢的做法，很有男子气概，诸如此类。而且我认为，这也深刻地扎根于历史，因为他的祖父曾是一名B特殊警察（B Special），他的父亲曾在阿尔斯特防卫团（Ulster Defence Regiment）服役。当被问及原因时，他将自己的动机定义为恐惧与爱的结合，恐惧于当时该地区可能发生和正在发生的事情，但同时也包含着对他整个传统以及他所长大的国家的更广泛的热爱。
And as he saw it, it was the natural thing to do to defend his family. You know, it's the brave thing to do, it's manly and so on. And it's also, I think, crucially rooted in history because his grandfather had been a B special, his father had been in the Ulster Defence Regiment. And when he was asked, he defined his motives as a combination of fear and love, fear for what could happen and what was happening in the area at the time, but also a wider sense of love for my whole tradition and the country that I'd grown up in.
恐惧和爱把他带向了何方？他16岁加入组织。到了20岁时，他因对一家他认为是爱尔兰共和军幌子的酒吧发动炸弹袭击而被判处无期徒刑。他的战友、朋友在炸弹提前引爆时身亡，同时丧生的还有当时在酒吧里的一名无辜妇女。他事后说，尽管在某种程度上我觉得自己可以为之辩护，但我却跌入了从未想过会涉足的深渊，跌入了从未知道其存在的深渊。当然，他代表了成千上万的其他民众。无论如何，让我们回到1971年春天的故事。
And where that fear and love took him, He joined when he was 16. By the time he was 20, he is serving a life sentence for a bomb attack on a pub that he believed was a front for the IRA. His comrade, his mate, was killed when the bomb went off prematurely, but also killed was an innocent woman who was in the pub at the time. And he said afterwards, although in some sense I felt I could justify it, I sank to depths I never thought I would go to. depths I never knew existed. And of course, he's speaking for thousands of other people. Anyway, back to the narrative in the spring of 1971.
因此，詹姆斯·奇切斯特-克拉克（James Chichester Clark），这位多少有些无能的首相，正面临着采取强力镇压的巨大压力。斯托蒙特议会大厦外爆发了示威游行，成千上万的造船厂工人、来自建造了泰坦尼克号的哈兰德与沃尔夫造船厂（Harland and Wolff Yard）的人们纷纷放下手中的工具，游行穿过贝尔法斯特，他们想要采取更强硬的路线。伊恩·佩斯利（Ian Paisley）
So James Chichester Clark, this slightly useless Prime Minister, is under great pressure to crack down. There are demonstrations outside Stormont, thousands of shipyard workers, people from the Harland and Wolf Yard that had built the Titanic. They down their tools, they march through Belfast, they want a harder line. Ian Paisley,
登场了。汤姆，你想给我们模仿一下伊恩·佩斯利吗？我们再也不能容忍你的软弱了。在全境被无辜男女的鲜血淹没之前，你必须下台！那么，奇切斯特-克拉克能做些什么呢？好吧，最大的问题是，他会实施拘禁吗？所谓的拘禁，是指未经审判就将嫌疑人关押起来。这听起来可能是一个极其极端的选择，
is on the scene. Tom, do you want to give us, Urien Paisley? We can no longer tolerate your weakness. You must go before the whole land is deluge with the blood of innocent men and women. So, what can Chichita Clark do? Well, the big question is, would he introduce internment? So internment means locking up suspects without trial. And that may sound like a very nuclear option,
但在爱尔兰却有着悠久的历史。英国政府在复活节起义后使用了它。爱尔兰自由邦的迈克尔·柯林斯（Michael Collins）等人曾在爱尔兰内战期间使用过它。贝尔法斯特和都柏林在第二次世界大战期间以及50年代末和60年代的爱尔兰共和军边境战役中都使用过它，而且它起作用了。基本上，他们知道谁是爱尔兰共和军的人。
but it has a long history in Ireland. The British government used it after the Easter Rising. The Irish Free State, Michael Collins and Co. used it during the Irish Civil War. Both Belfast and Dublin used it in the Second World War and in the border campaign, the IRA border campaign of the late 50s and 60s, and it worked. Basically, they knew who the IRA men were.
他们掌握着情报，于是他们去把这些人抓起来，未经审判就将他们关押，从而摧毁了爱尔兰共和军的中坚力量。事实上，爱尔兰政府在当时关于爱尔兰共和军和整个共和主义的问题上总是有点人格分裂，因为爱尔兰政府名义上致力于实现爱尔兰统一，但也致力于粉碎它视为非法恐怖组织的爱尔兰共和军。因此它左右为难，受到双向拉扯。1970年，都柏林政府公开威胁要恢复拘禁，一年后，他们取消了针对爱尔兰共和军嫌疑人的陪审团审判。所以他们实际上经常采取相当强硬的路线。
They had intelligence that told them. they went and grabbed them and they locked them up without trial and they broke the back of the IRA. And in fact, the Irish government, which is always a bit schizophrenic, I think, at this point about the IRA and republicanism generally, because of course the Irish government is nominally committed to a United Ireland, but it's also committed to smashing the IRA, which it regards as an illegal terror group. So it's sort of torn and it's pulled in two directions. In 1970, the Dublin government publicly threatened to bring back internment, and a year later they scrapped jury trials for IRA suspects. So often they do actually take a pretty hard line.
甚至在北方，一些温和的民族主义者也对英国人说，你知道吗，如果你恢复拘禁，我们勉强也能接受。所以杰里·菲特（Jerry Fitt），我们我想上次见过他。那个占领了大臣官邸的人。那个房主是奥斯汀·柯里（Austin Curry）。杰里·菲特就是那个以前做过某种工作的人，我记得他以前在船上工作。他后来不是成了国会议员吗？他成了国会议员。他成了国会议员。
And some, even in the north, some moderate nationalists say to the British, do you know what, we could kind of live with it if you brought back internment? So Jerry Fitt, who we met, I think last time. The guy who occupied the secretary's house. The houseman was Austin Curry. Jerry Fitt is the bloke used to work as a sort of, he used to work on the ships, I think. Didn't he become an MP? He became an MP. He became an MP.
和吉姆·卡拉汉（Jim Callahan）是好朋友。我以为他是其中之一。他是占领大臣官邸的人之一。不，那是奥斯汀·柯里和他的几个朋友。哦，好吧。无论如何，杰里·菲特向英国人建议，他对他们说，我引用原话：“立即拘禁警方所知的全体临时派爱尔兰共和军成员。”但是首相奇切斯特-克拉克实际上认为，
Mates with Jim Callahan. I thought he was one of them. He was one of the people who occupied the Secretary's House. No, it's Austin Curry and a couple of his friends. Oh, okay. Anyway, Jerry Fitt suggests to the British, she says to them, and I quote, the immediate internment of all provisional IRA men known to the police. But Chichester Clark, the Prime Minister, actually think,
这真是个糟糕的主意。原因在于军队和警察告诉他：“我们没有很好的情报。所以我们抓不到对的人。这很可能会引发大规模抗议，并让北爱尔兰陷入无法治理的境地。”因此，奇切斯特-克拉克于1971年3月16日飞往伦敦。他对希思和莫德林说：“我不想让你们实施拘禁。”
That's quite a bad idea. And the reason for that is that the army and the police have told him, we don't have very good intelligence. So we won't pick up the right people. And it will probably provoke massive protests and make Northern Ireland ungovernable. So Chichita Clark flies off to London on the 16th of March, 1971. And he says to Heath and to Mordling, I don't want you to introduce internment.
我想要一次军事增兵，就像2007年彼得雷乌斯将军在伊拉克的军事增兵那样。基本上，我希望你们投入兵力，用军队淹没北爱尔兰，向天主教徒聚居区投放数千名增援部队，实施宵禁、警戒线封锁、全面封锁，所有这些都要搞起来。希思对他说：
I want a military surge, like a general Petraeus, military surge from 2007 in Iraq. Basically, I want you to throw in, I'm going to flood Northern Ireland with troops, throw thousands of reinforcements into the Catholic estates, go through curfews, cordons, lockdowns, all of this. And Heath says to him,
“我不会派驻大量额外军队。你可以多得一千名士兵，但我的意思是，我不会投掷几万名英国士兵进去。”奇切斯特-克拉克对此感到彻底泄气。他想，好吧，这毫无意义。你知道的，我的底牌已经打光了。我什么也做不了。
I'm not going to send in loads of extra troops. You can have a thousand more troops, but I mean, I'm not going to hurl in tens of thousands of British soldiers. Chichester Clark is completely, deflated by this. He thinks, well, this is pointless. You know, I've shot my bolt. There's nothing I can do.
他飞回贝尔法斯特，两天后，他决定辞去首相职务。哦，去花更多时间陪伴他的奶牛吗？正是如此。他决定，我不想打电话给特德·希思（Ted Heath），因为特德·希思在电话里太糟糕了。他太冷漠了。喂。对，没错。
He flies back to Belfast, and then two days later, he decides I'm going to resign as Prime Minister. Oh, spend more time with his cowers. Exactly so. And he decides, I don't want to ring Ted Heath because Ted Heath is terrible on the phone. He's so glacial. Hello. Yeah, exactly.
我不打算打电话给特德·希思。他想我还是打给雷吉纳德·莫德林（Reginald Maudling）吧。抱歉。他打给莫德林。这简直超越了恶搞的极限。莫德林，他打不通，因为莫德林正在一家历史悠久的公立学校——泰勒商人之校（Merchant Taylor's School）发表演讲。莫德林的特别分局特工找到他说，北爱尔兰首相在线。他有急事要找你谈。
I'm not going to ring Ted Heath. He thinks I'll ring Reginal Mordling. Sorry. He rings Mordling. This is absolutely beyond parody. Mordling, he can't get through because Mordling is giving a lecture at Merchant Taylor's School, a very well-established public school. Mordling's special branch men go to find him to say the Prime Minister of Northern Ireland is on the line. He wants to talk to you urgently.
但他们发现他没有在做演讲，而是和校长关起门来，我引述原话：“吃了一顿完全由威士忌组成的午餐。”所以我不知道这说明莫德林还是泰勒商人之校有什么问题。没什么好话。哦，校长。没错，对。你难道不是在经营一所学校吗？看在上帝的份上，老兄。这才是这个故事真正的丑闻。
But they find him not giving the talk, but closeted with the headmaster, and I quote, having a lunch made up entirely of whiskey. So I don't know what that says either about Mordling or indeed about Merchant Taylor's school. Nothing good. Oh, the headmaster. Right, exactly. Are you not running a school? For God's sake, man. That's the real scandal of this story.
不管怎样，莫德林最终被说服叫了一辆车送他回伦敦接听这个电话。但当他们在路上时，汽车在沃特福德神秘地抛锚了。因此他无法接听詹姆斯·奇切斯特-克拉克的电话。莫德林的传记作家路易斯·巴塞特（Louis Bassett）
Anyway, Mordling eventually is persuaded to summon a car to take him back to London to take this call. But when they're on their way, the car mysteriously breaks down in Watford. So he is unable to take the call from James Chichester Clark. And Mordling's biographer, Louis Bassett. and I think says basically what happened was that Maudling was so drunk after this liquid lunch that his officials decided
我想他基本上说发生的事情是莫德林在喝了这顿“液体午餐”后醉得太厉害了，以至于他的官员们认为他们绝对不能冒险让他……是的，就把车开到应急车道上停下。正是如此。所以詹姆斯·奇切斯特-克拉克不得不改去打电话给特德·希思，而这正是他一直极力想要避免的。
they couldn't possibly risk him Yeah, just pull into a light lay by Exactly So James Chiches-A-Clark has to ring Ted Heath Instead which he's been trying to get out of And Heath is incredibly rude to him of course refuses to listen to anything he says Keep saying to him
希思对他的态度极其粗鲁，当然拒绝听他说的任何话。一直对他说：
You can't give me a single example How can you say we're just sitting there and doing nothing? And at the end Chichester Clark almost in sort of desperation said, well, I'm going to resign and are going to blame the British Army. I'm going to say all the British Army's thought they let us down. And Heath goes absolutely berserk. You do quite a good Ted Heath. So do you want to do Ted Heath now?
“你连一个例子都举不出来。你怎么能说我们只是坐在那里什么都不做呢？”最后，奇切斯特-克拉克几乎带着绝望的语气说，好吧，我要辞职了，还要指责英军。我要说英军觉得他们辜负了我们。希思彻底暴怒了。你模仿特德·希思模仿得挺像的。那你现在要不要来模仿一下特德·希思？
I consider that absolutely unjustifiable. It bears very little relation to the truth. I think it is doing immense harm to Northern Ireland. And I think it makes the position of any successor of yours absolutely impossible. And then Chichita Clark sort of blusters. He says, well, I don't do anything unhelpful. And Heath says, I don't think there's anything more to discuss. and he just hangs up on him.
我认为那绝对是无法辩解的。它与事实几乎没有任何关系。我认为这对北爱尔兰造成了巨大的损害。而且我认为这让你的任何继任者的立场都变得绝对不可能。然后奇切斯特-克拉克有点大声嚷嚷。他说，好吧，我不会做什么无益的事。希思说，我想没什么好讨论的了。然后他就直接挂断了电话。
And that's the end of that. That's the end of James Chichester Clark in this story. Is he all right? Does he enjoy go back to his farming? I think he goes back to his farm. It's all okay? Well, I mean, it's all okay insofar as it possibly can be, as his country collapses around him. Yeah.
事情就这样结束了。詹姆斯·奇切斯特-克拉克在这个故事里的戏份就此结束。他没事吧？他喜欢回去种地吗？我想他回农场去了。一切都好吗？嗯，我是说，在国家在他周围崩溃的情况下，只要还能过得去，就都还算好吧。
So he's out. Now, finally, the Ulster Unionist aside, well, we've had two Etonians. Let's look beyond the old Etonian class for somebody who's actually quite good at politics. And they get in another bloke. And this bloke is called Brian Faulkner. Oh, yes. He went to school in Dublin with W.B. Yates' son. Correct.
所以他下台了。现在，最后，抛开阿尔斯特统一派不谈，好吧，我们已经有两个伊顿公学毕业生了。让我们跳出老伊顿阶层，找一个真正擅长政治的人。他们又找来了另一个家伙。这个家伙叫布赖恩·福克纳（Brian Faulkner）。哦，是的。他曾在都柏林和W·B·叶芝的儿子一起上过学。没错。
He absolutely did. That's the amazing fact I know about him. And here's an amazing fact. You know, who also went to that school? So he went to St. Columbus in Dublin, which builds itself, I googled it. It bills itself as the most prestigious school in Ireland, the best boarding school in Ireland. Brian Faulkner went there, W.B. Yates sent his son there. Adam Clayton from U-2 went there.
他确实去过。这是我知道关于他的惊人事实。这里还有一个惊人事实。你知道谁也去过那所学校吗？所以他去了都柏林的圣科伦巴学校（St. Columbus），我谷歌过它。它自诩为爱尔兰最负盛名的学校，爱尔兰最好的寄宿学校。布赖恩·福克纳去过那里，W·B·叶芝把他的儿子送到了那里。U2乐队的亚当·克莱顿（Adam Clayton）也去过那里。
Did he? You too don't often talk about their boarding school backgrounds, did they? And they're playing bloody Sunday. That changes their image a little bit, I think. It's great to out people as the products of prestigious boarding schools, I think, on the show. I think it's one of the things we specialise. So Brian Faulkner, his father had run and founded, in fact, the world's largest shirt makers. So the Belfast Collar Company make more shirts than anybody else.
是吗？你们两个也经常不谈他们的寄宿学校背景，不是吗？而且他们还在演《血腥星期天》。我认为，这稍微改变了一点他们的形象。我认为，在节目里揭露大家都是名牌寄宿学校的产物，这很棒。我认为这是我们的专长之一。所以布赖恩·福克纳，他的父亲经营并创办了实际上是全球最大的衬衫制造商。因此，贝尔法斯特领子公司的衬衫产量比其他任何公司都多。
else on the planet. And he'd gone off to St. Columbus, and then he'd gone into politics. Fulkener is very good at politics. He's cunning. He's kind of no nonsense. He's incredibly ambitious. He is the champion of the kind of Protestant middle classes of small businessmen. If you're a small businessman, you love Brian Fultner. He'd been the Home Affairs Minister during the IRA border campaign. He'd been very hard. He'd taken the credit for beating them. Under Terence O'Neill, he'd been the Minister of Commerce. He'd been getting all this international investment. He thinks a lot of him. He thinks he's the only man who can keep Northern Ireland together. Fultner agrees and thinks I am the only man who can do it. I'm the champion of law and order. I'm the saviour of Northern Ireland and all this. But he has a terrible inheritance. Basically, the security situation is awful. There are bombs going off every day, the thump of explosions, the smell of cordite, the sound of sirens. These are becoming everyday features of life in Belfast. And by the 12th of July, so that's when the Provo's launch a new bombing campaign. There will already be more than 300
比地球上其他任何地方都多。他曾就读于圣哥伦布学校，后来步入政坛。福克纳非常擅长政术。他很狡猾。他是个务实不废话的人。他有着极强的野心。他是新教中产阶级和小商人们的拥护者。如果你是个小商人，你就会深爱布赖恩·福克纳。在爱尔兰共和军边境竞选期间，他曾担任内政大臣。他的手段非常强硬。他将击溃对方的功劳归于自己。在特伦斯·奥尼尔手下，他曾担任商业大臣。他引进了所有这些国际投资。奥尼尔非常器重他。他认为福克纳是唯一能将北爱尔兰团结在一起的人。福克纳也表示赞同，认为我才是唯一能做到这一点的人。我是法律与秩序的捍卫者。我是北爱尔兰的救世主，诸如此类。但他接手的是一个烂摊子。基本上，安全局势糟透了。每天都有炸弹爆炸，爆炸的闷响、无烟火药的气味、刺耳的警笛声。这些正在成为贝尔法斯特生活的日常特色。到了7月12日，也就是临时派发动新一轮炸弹袭击的时候。届时将已经发生300多起
explosions, 320 shootings, 600 people hospitalized and the death toll for 1971 will come to 171, which is up sixfold in a year. So what Faulkner does, Faulkner thinks, right, I'm going to offer some concessions to the Catholics. We mentioned Jerry Fitt and you mentioned you asked if he was the same person as Austin Curry, the guy who had occupied had the Pebble Dash Council House. And actually both of these blokes had set up this new party, the SDLP,
爆炸案、320起枪击案、600人住院治疗，1971年的死亡人数将达到171人，比前一年激增了六倍。因此，福克纳采取的行动是，福克纳心想，好吧，我要对天主教徒做出一些让步。我们提到了杰里·菲特，而你曾提到并询问他是否就是那个奥斯丁·柯瑞，那个曾经占领过卵石防风砂浆市政公屋的人。事实上，正是这两个家伙组建了这个新政党——社会民主工党（SDLP），
which is a kind of moderate nationalist party. And Faulkner decides, I'm going to offer them an olive branch. It's a brilliant olive branch. I'm going to offer them the chairmanship of two storm on committees. Yeah, so enticing. So he's going to offer them this, right?
这是一个温和的民族主义政党。福克纳决定，我要向他们伸出橄榄枝。这是一个绝妙的橄榄枝。我要让他们担任两个斯托蒙特委员会的主席。是的，太诱人了。所以他打算向他们提供这个，对吧？
But then to balance this tremendous offer, he has to do something for the Protestant base. So he decides to take a big gamble. He flies to Britain and he asks Heath, he says, I'd like to introduce interment. I'd like to be able to lock people up without trial. Now, Heath is very well aware of the arguments against this. British Army intelligence have said to him, we'll catch one in five provisional IRA men. We'll probably catch only the lesser people, the small fry, as they put it. The RUC, the Royal Ulster Constabulary, have also told him the IRA have loads of young people now who we don't know and we won't know who they are and we can't pick them up.
但随后，为了平衡这份巨大的提议，他必须为新教徒基本盘做点什么。于是他决定下一盘大棋。他飞往英国，要求希思同意，他说，我想引入拘禁制度。我想在未经审判的情况下关押嫌疑人。现在，希思对反对这一做法的种种论点心知肚明。英国陆军情报部门曾对他说，我们只能抓到五分之一的临时爱尔兰共和军成员。我们可能只会抓到那些无足轻重的小角色，用他们的话说就是虾兵蟹将。皇家阿尔斯特警察部队（RUC）也告诉他，爱尔兰共和军现在有很多我们不认识的年轻人，我们根本不知道他们是谁，也无法将他们抓获。
Even the British commander in Belfast, the new British commander, Sir Harry Tuzzo, he says to Heath, I think the arguments against it are very strong. If you do this, be clear about this. This is a political decision, not a military one. And on top of all that, the T-Shok, the Prime Minister of the Republic of Ireland, Jack Lynch, has said to the British ambassador, I really don't think you should do this. It will drive the Catholics into the arms of the IRA. I am basically begging you not to do it. The problem for Heath, though,
就连驻贝尔法斯特的新任英国最高指挥官、爵士哈里·图佐也对希思说，我认为反对这一做法的理由非常充分。如果你要这么做，请务必认清这一点。这是一个政治决定，而不是军事决定。不仅如此，爱尔兰共和国总理（陶谢赫）杰克·林奇也对英国大使表示，我真的认为你们不应该这么做。这会将天主教徒推向爱尔兰共和军的怀抱。我在此恳求你们千万不要这么做。然而，对希思而言，问题在于……
Heath is totally committed to Brian Faulkner. If Heath says no, and if Brian Faulkner says, well, that's it, I'm out, I'm done. Then Britain has no alternative but to introduce direct rule. And nobody in London wants to do that. And Reggie Mordling, you know, who's basically woken up now from his gin-soaked sleep. What's going on?
希思对布赖恩·福克纳是绝对支持的。如果希思拒绝，而布赖恩·福克纳说，好吧，那就这样吧，我不干了，我退出。那么英国除了实行直接统治外，别无选择。而伦敦没有任何人愿意这么做。至于雷吉·莫德林，你知道的，他现在基本上从杜松子酒带来的醉梦中醒来了。怎么回事？
Yeah. Says to Ted Heath, look, the way to justify this, we say to people, this is the only way to sort of forestall a Protestant backlash against the Catholics. You know, actually, maybe the army are being too pessimistic. Maybe we'll get loads of people and it'll be fine. And so Heath says, okay, let's do it. So basically, people who know nothing about the situation are overruling people who know loads about it. That's pretty much exactly what's happened. Yes. But you can understand why they've
是的。他对特德·希思说，听着，为这事辩解的办法，就是对大家说，这是阻止新教徒对天主教徒进行强烈反弹的唯一途径。你知道，其实，也许军队太悲观了。也许我们会抓到一大批人，一切都会没事的。于是希思说，好吧，那就这么办吧。所以基本上，对局势一无所知的人正在推翻那些对局势了如指掌的人。情况差不多就是这样。是的。但你可以理解他们为什么
done it because if they're all in with Brian Faulkner, what else are they going to do? Find someone else. You know, I suppose they'd call his bluff. Or they could introduce direct rule right away, which may be arguably they should have done about two years earlier. That is one argument that you could make that basically the opportunity was missed in like 1969. They should have taken it over right away. But anyway, they didn't. So he says to Brian Faulkner, fine, you can introduce internment, it's a purely political decision, not military. So because of that, it must look even-handed. So what I want you to do, it must go along with a ban for six months and all-loyalist, you know, orange order parades and marches and stuff. Fulton is not happy about
这么做，因为如果他们全盘押注在布赖恩·福克纳身上，他们还能怎么办？去找别人吗？你知道，我想他们会选择戳穿他的虚张声势。或者他们可以立刻实行直接统治，或许可以说他们本应该在两年前就这么做了。这是一种你可以提出的观点，即基本上在1969年左右就错失了良机。他们本该立刻接管局势。但无论如何，他们没有这么做。所以他对布赖恩·福克纳说，好吧，你可以实行拘禁，这是一个纯粹的政治决定，而不是军事决定。正因为如此，它必须看起来公正无私。所以我要你做的是，它必须伴随着一项为期六个月的禁令，禁止所有保皇派、你知道的，橙色注文游行和游行活动等等。福克纳对此并不高兴，
this because it will upset his base, but he says, no, you've got to do it. And then the other thing that he says, which is absolutely crucial, says when you look up people without trial, You must, and I quote, include a certain number of Protestants. And Faulkner clearly doesn't like this, but he says, yeah, I hear you. Now, we shall see how that plays out. So on Monday the 9th of August, 1971, it's actually A-level results day, interestingly. At 4 o'clock in the morning, Operation Demetrius, as it is called, begins. And I always think Operation Demetrius sounds like a brilliant name for something.
因为这会惹恼他的基本盘，但他说，不，你必须这么做。然后他说的另一件事绝对至关重要，那就是当你们在没有审判的情况下关押人员时，你们必须——请允许我引用原话——“包括一定数量的新教徒”。福克纳显然不喜欢这样，但他还是说，好吧，我听懂了。现在，我们将拭目以待事情会如何发展。因此，在1971年8月9日星期一，有趣的是，这天其实是A-Level考试成绩公布日。清晨4点，“德米特里乌斯行动”（Operation Demetrius）正式开始。我一直觉得“德米特里乌斯行动”听起来像是个极其炫酷的代号。
It sounds like an incredibly daring swashbuckling raid in the Second World War. I can imagine your brother and Al Murray doing an amazing four-part series on it. Surely a multi-part series about Operation Demetrius. Wasn't there an Eric Ambler novel, The Mask of Demetrius? Yes, exactly, set in Constantinople. So it conjures up a kind of a kind of Balkan spy adventure. We shall see whether this lives up to the expectations. So before dawn, thousands of British troops sealing off streets across northern.
这听起来像是一次二战中极其大胆、惊心动魄的突袭。我可以想象你哥哥和阿尔·默里在做一个精彩的四集系列节目。肯定是一个关于“德米特里乌斯行动”的多集系列节目。难道没有一本埃里克·安布勒的小说叫《德米特里乌斯的面具》吗？是的，没错，故事背景设在君士坦丁堡。所以这让人联想起一种巴尔干间谍冒险故事。我们将拭目以待这是否符合预期。因此，在黎明前，数千名英国士兵封锁了北爱尔兰各地的街道。
Northern Ireland. They're smashing down people's doors, they're breaking into their houses, and they're dragging out hundreds of people who are on these lists. And it's a very dramatic, it's a very cinematic scene, although I can't help thinking that if you were to see this on the big screen, you would assume the people doing the dragging out are the villains. It's very unusual for the people doing the dragging to be the heroes in the story. Well, especially if it's a provisional IRA film club, that's what you would assume. That's, I guess. So, If it's a Ken Loach film, then undoubtedly they're the villains. They're dragging Daniel Day Lewis out and Pete Posse Thwait or something.
北爱尔兰。他们砸毁人们的大门，破门而入，把名单上的数百人强行拖出来。这是一个非常戏剧化、非常具有电影感的场景，尽管我禁不住想，如果你在大银幕上看到这一幕，你会以为那些强行把人拖出来的人是大反派。在这个故事里，执行拖拽的人居然是英雄，这非常罕见。好吧，特别是如果这是一个临时爱尔兰共和军电影俱乐部，你肯定会这么认为。我想是这样的。所以，如果这是一部肯·洛奇的电影，那么毫无疑问他们就是反派。他们把丹尼尔·戴-刘易斯和皮特·波斯尔thwaite或什么人给拖了出来。
Anyway, we'll come to the optics of this in a second. But it's important to say that as a military operation, this is an absolute unmitigated shambles. The army are using RUC intelligence files. But as everybody has told Heath, these files are massively out of date. They don't reflect the split between the official and provisional IRA. they don't reflect the fact that loads of young volunteers have joined the provisionals. Loads of the names are wrong. They don't get most of the key people.
无论如何，我们一会儿再谈这些视觉效果。但必须要说的是，作为一次军事行动，这绝对是一场彻头彻尾、无可救药的混乱。军队使用的是皇家阿尔斯特警察部队（RUC）的情报档案。但正如所有人对希思所说的那样，这些档案已经严重过时了。它们根本无法反映官方爱尔兰共和军与临时爱尔兰共和军之间的分裂。它们也没有反映出大量年轻志愿者加入了临时派这一事实。许多名字都是错的。他们根本没抓到几个核心人物。
There's a wonderful story in what I can't remember what book this is in, about a British officer who went at 4 o'clock in the morning, he burst into this bloke's house. And he finds this bloke who's clearly in his 80s. And this bloke says to him, when he drags him out of bed, this bloke says to him, I'm delighted to think that I'm still of trouble to the British government, but I have to tell you, I've not been acting.
有一个精彩的故事，我不记得是在哪本书里看到的了，讲的是一个英国军官在凌晨4点冲进了一个家伙的家里。他发现这个家伙显然已经80多岁了。当军官把他从床上拖起来时，这老头对他说，我很高兴能让英国政府感到头疼，但我必须告诉你，自从复活节起义以来，我可就没再采取过任何行动了。
since the Easter rising. Well, he would say that, wouldn't he? I suppose he would. So some of the people they take are teenagers who are just very nationalistic. At least one teenager is on the list purely because he plays Gaelic Games. Paul Rouse wouldn't approve of that, would he?
好吧，他当然会这么说，不是吗？我想他会的。所以他们抓走的一些人只是思想极度民族主义的十几岁青少年。至少有一个青少年上榜纯粹是因为他参加了盖尔式运动。保罗·劳斯可不会赞同这一点，对吧？
Paul Rouse. Paul Rouse would have been dragged out, you see, because of his enthusiasm for Gaelic Games. Yeah. They arrested in total 342 people and took them to internment camps. Now, given what Heath had said to him about, make sure you have a good balance.
保罗·劳斯。你看，保罗·劳斯要是被拖出来，肯定是因为他对盖尔式运动的热情。是的。他们总共逮捕了342人，并将他们送往拘禁营。现在，考虑到希思之前对他说过，一定要确保做好平衡。
So what is the balance, Dominic? So the balance is as follows. Out of 342, the balance is Catholics, 342. Protestants, zero. Why? They just couldn't be bothered in the end to get any Protestants. Well, actually, I'll let Reginald Mordling answer this question. So I'll leap ahead to tell you what Reginald Mordling said in interviews afterwards.
那么，多米尼克，这个平衡在哪里呢？所以平衡情况如下。在342人中，平衡的结果是：天主教徒，342人。新教徒，零。为什么？因为到头来他们根本懒得去抓任何新教徒。好吧，其实，我让雷吉纳德·莫德林来回答这个问题。所以我先跳到前面来告诉大家雷吉纳德·莫德林事后在采访中说了什么。
The newspaper said to him, why didn't you arrest loyalists? And he said, well, if any Protestant organizations were behaving like, the RRA, we should have treated them in precisely the same way. But the thing is, they had actually believed. The first killings were done by the UVF. Well, those guys shooting people in pubs. Right, exactly. So of course, this sets off this absolute, you know, furorory. Extraordinary scenes, actually why it's going on in Northern Ireland. So women will be banging dustbin lids when there are British troops approaching. There are people building barricades to stop and getting into the streets, people commandeering milk carts to use the bottles for petrol bombs. There's gigantic
报纸问他，你们为什么不逮捕保皇派武装？他说，好吧，如果有任何新教组织表现得像阿尔斯特志愿军（UVF）那样，我们本就会以完全相同的方式对待他们。但问题是，他们居然真的相信。第一起谋杀案是由乌夫（UVF）制造的。对，就是那些在酒吧里枪杀别人的人。没错，绝对是的。所以，这自然引发了一场轩然大波。实际上，在北爱尔兰正发生着极其罕见的场景：当英国军队逼近时，女人们会疯狂敲击垃圾桶盖。人们修建路障来阻止军队进入街道，人们甚至征用送奶车，用里面的玻璃瓶来制作燃烧弹。随后几天发生了大规模的
rioting and the days afterwards, hundreds of houses set on fire by sectarian mobs of one kind or another. Seven thousand people were driven from their homes by mob violence. Great clouds of black smoke over Belfast Estates. 17 people shot dead in gun battles with the army. It's a screen of complete apocalyptic breakdown. and everything has gone horrendously wrong. So, as you say, apocalyptic, what does the judge dread of the British Conservative government make of this Reginal Mordling? Has he sobered up to deal with it? Not entirely.
骚乱，数千所房屋被各种派别的宗派暴徒放火焚烧。7,000人因暴民暴力而被驱逐出家园。贝尔法斯特住宅区上空漂浮着滚滚黑烟。17人在与军队的枪战中被枪杀。这是一幅彻底走向末日崩溃的景象。一切都大错特错了。正如你所说，末日般的景象，英国保守党政府的这位“活阎王”雷吉纳德·莫德林对此作何感想？他酒醒了吗？并没有完全清醒。
So it's actually been a lovely day in suburban Hertfordshire where he lives. And Reggie has been chilling by his swimming pool with a bottle of gin. So he's been relaxing. And every now and again, he rouses himself from his lounge. to go ring Whitehorn to say, you know, how's it going? And they tell him and he said, oh, sounds splendid, absolutely splendid. And he goes back to the sun lounger. And I mean, it's a reminder, isn't it?
所以这其实是他在赫特福德郡郊区住所的一个美好日子，他平时就住在那里。雷吉一直和一瓶杜松子酒在游泳池边优哉游哉地乘凉。所以他一直在放松。每隔一会儿，他就会从躺椅上直起身子，
That, of course, ministers cannot keep track minute by minute of what is going on because the technological opportunities to do that are not in existence. And I guess that is something to bear in mind. Tom, this sounds like you're defending Reginald Mordland. I'm defending him. You know, a chap, it's a beautiful summer's day. A chap wants to hang out and drink gin. He doesn't want to be bothered with all this nonsense.
给白厅打电话问问，你知道的，情况怎么样？他们告诉了他，他说，哦，听起来棒极了，绝对棒极了。然后他又回到了太阳椅上。我的意思是，这真是一个提醒，不是吗？
Yeah. I mean, he disgraces himself, actually, because afterwards, when he's interviewed, he tells the Guardian, we did this on army advice with the army who told us to do it. That's so bad. That's poor, yeah. And his biographer, Lewis Baston,
那就是，当然，由于当时缺乏相应的技术手段，部长们无法对正在发生的事情进行分分秒秒的追踪。我想这也是需要铭记的一点。汤姆，听起来你是在为雷吉纳德·莫德林辩护。我是在为他辩护吗？你知道的，一个家伙，赶上了一个美丽的夏日。一个家伙只想闲逛并喝点杜松子酒。他才不想被所有这些废话打扰呢。
so Louis Baston came on a bonus last year to talk about borderlands, which is his big enthusiasm now. So we was talking about the Silesian border, slightly implausibly. But anyway, he says in his biography, which is called Reggie, he says this was an outright lie from more.
是的。我的意思是，事实上他自取其辱，因为事后在接受采访时，他对《卫报》说，我们是在军队的建议下这么做的，是军队告诉我们这么做的。这太糟糕了。这确实很逊，是的。他的传记作家路易斯·巴斯顿——
Which it was. Yeah, a total lie. Yeah. Bastian also describes this as, quote, one of the great blunders of recent British political history. It absolutely is. So basically, everyone says introducing internment was a total own goal. Had it worked, would it? I mean, had they got the right people, maybe it would have worked, do you think? Well, it might have been a price worth paying if you'd absolutely got the right people. If you'd literally... You've broken the IRA. Yeah. The IRA has all 1,000 people at this point. Imagine you locked up 500 of them.
所以路易斯·巴斯顿去年曾作为特邀嘉宾来聊过边境地区，这现在是他的狂热爱好。所以我们当时在略显荒谬地讨论西里西亚边境。无论如何，他在自己名为《雷吉》的传记中说，这完全是莫德林的一派谎言。
Well, you were not going to get all 1,000, but you might get hundreds and hundreds of the senior people, break the back of the organization. You know, maybe that would work. Unfortunately, they absolutely didn't. They didn't get any of the right people. So are shambles. And it completely drives a wedge between moderate nationalist politicians and the authorities. And it completes what the falls curfew had begun. It destroys the relationship forever between the army and the Catholic population.
事实的确如此。是的，纯属谎言。是的。巴斯顿还将此描述为“近代英国政治史上的一大重大失误”。它绝对是。所以基本上，每个人都认为引入拘禁是一个彻头彻尾的乌龙球。如果它成功了呢？我的意思是，如果他们抓对了人，也许它会成功，你觉得呢？嗯，如果你真的抓对了人，这或许是一个值得付出的代价。如果你真的……你击溃了爱尔兰共和军。是的。当时爱尔兰共和军总共只有大约1000人。想象一下，你关押了其中的500人。
So, you know, there's no going back now. And, of course, the winners from this are the provisional IRA, because they've got their arms intact. They get loads of new recruits. And on Catholic estates, their reputation is higher than ever. Now, what makes this worse? What makes this far worse is what happens to the people interned. They are interned at a disused airfield at a place called Longcash,
好吧，你不可能抓到全部1000人，但你可能会抓到成百上千的高层人物，从而彻底瓦解这个组织的骨干。你知道，也许那样就行得通了。不幸的是，他们根本没有做到。他们一个真正的重要人物都没抓到。所以这是一场彻头彻尾的混乱。它彻底在温和派民族主义政治家和当局之间打入了一个楔子。它完成了福尔斯宵禁所开始的事情，永远摧毁了军队与天主教人口之间的关系。
in these sort of low, corrugated iron Nissen huts. Imagine, again, your brother and Al Murray love a nissons. and Hut, sort of World War II relic. The people in these huts are being tortured by the Army and by the IUC. They are being, you get the first reports in Irish newspapers, the people being dragged out of bed, 2 o'clock in the morning, and sort of beaten up and battered against the wall. And the army and Stormont, the government, say this is a lie.
所以，你知道，现在已经没有回头路了。当然，从这件事中获益最大的是临时爱尔兰共和军，因为他们的武装依然完好无损。他们招募到了大批新兵。在天主教居民区，他们的声望比以往任何时候都要高。现在，更糟糕的是什么？让情况变得更糟的是被拘禁者的遭遇。他们被关押在一个废弃的机场里，位于一个叫做长开（Long Cash）的地方，
This is IRA propaganda. But it's actually not a lie, it's true. And what does Reginald-Mortland think about this? He thinks it's brilliant. I think this is exactly what you should be doing. Does he? Yes. Because the army in the IUC, it had meetings before internment to talk about what they would do
关在那种低矮的、波纹铁皮的尼森小屋（Nissen huts）里。想象一下，再次借用你哥哥和阿尔·默里对尼森小屋的喜爱，那种二战时期的遗迹。关在这些小屋里的人正遭受着军队和皇家阿尔斯特警察部队的酷刑折磨。他们正——爱尔兰报纸上出现了最早的报道，讲述人们在凌晨2点被从床上拖出来，遭受殴打并撞向墙壁。而军队和斯托蒙特政府则声称这是谎言。
and they'd agreed to adopt something called the Five Techniques. And the five techniques are making you stand spread eagled for ages, putting a hood over your head, playing white noise at you, giving you a minimum of bread and water. So just enough to keep you alive basically. But you know, you're thirsty and famished or whatever. And you're deprived of sleep. So this is what they'd done in Malaya, wasn't it, to break the insurgency there? In Malaya, in Palestine, in Kenya, in Cyprus.
这是爱尔兰共和军的宣传。但它其实不是谎言，千真万确。雷吉纳德·莫德林对此怎么看？他觉得这太棒了。他认为这正是你们应该做的事。是吗？是的。因为军队和皇家阿尔斯特警察部队在拘禁行动开始前曾举行会议，商讨他们将采取什么手段，
This was an established British colonial practice. And it's extraordinary, I think to me, that the army thought they could, I mean, people will have their own views, of course, about whether such techniques are permissible. It's a big debate in Iraq, in Afghanistan. Yeah. That people that they thought they could do this in a part of the United Kingdom. Kingdom against United Kingdom citizens is pretty remarkable. Or is it? Because in the government, do they see Northern Ireland really? So there are definitely historians who say this shows the
并且他们同意采用一种名为“五项技术”的方法。这五项技术包括：强迫你双臂双腿叉开呈大字形站立很长时间、头上套上头套、对你播放白噪音、只提供最低限度的面包和水。基本上就是仅够维持你生命的量。但你知道的，你会感到口渴和饥饿等等。而且你被剥夺了睡眠。所以他们在马来亚就是这么做的，对吧，为了瓦解那里的叛乱？在马来亚、在巴勒斯坦、在肯尼亚、在塞浦路斯。
colonial mindset. They wouldn't do this in Berkshire, but they think it's okay to do it in Ulster. Absolutely you're right. And the amazing thing is they have explicit government approval for it because you asked about marginal modelling. The Defence Secretary of Lord Carrington later told a cabinet committee, he said, Reggie and I explicitly approved the proposed methods of interrogation. So to read the minutes of the cabinet committee, the lives of British soldiers and innocent civilians depended on intelligence. We were dealing with an enemy who had no scruples, and we should not be unduly squeamish over methods of interrogation in these circumstances. So they're completely open about it with their colleagues. Now, of course, they can't keep this
这是英国殖民地的一套既定惯例。我认为这对我来说非常不可思议，军队竟然以为他们可以——当然，对于这种技术是否被允许，人们会有自己的看法。这是伊拉克和阿富汗战争中的一场大辩论。是的。他们竟然以为可以在联合国内部的一个地方、针对联合国的公民这样做，这真是相当了不起。或者真的是这样吗？因为在政府内部，他们真的把北爱尔兰当回事吗？因此，绝对有历史学家指出，这展现出了
quiet. It was amazing they thought they could. The Sunday Times did a big investigation. The Sunday Times Insight team listed 11 separate cases of torture. The government commissioned a report by three judges. Two of the judges said it's fine, but the third judge, Lord Gardner said, these techniques are secret, illegal, not morally justifiable and alien to the traditions of what I believe still to be the greatest democracy in the world. I see that he no longer believed that Britain was the greatest democracy in the world then if he framed it like that. Yeah, I mean, when a judge says that, there's no going back. You know, you're sunk. Ted Heath immediately when that came out, said, okay, fine, we won't use them again. But there's a brilliant letter actually by Graham Green. Graham Green said to the time, wrote to the
殖民地的心态。他们不会在伯克希尔这样做，但他们觉得在阿尔斯特这样做是可以的。你完全说得对。而令人惊叹的是，他们得到了政府的明确批准，因为你刚才问到了雷吉纳德·莫德林。国防大臣卡灵顿勋爵后来对一个内阁委员会说，我和雷吉明确批准了拟议的审讯方法。因此，阅读内阁委员会的会议记录就会发现，英国士兵和无辜平民的生命取决于情报。我们面对的是一个毫无底线的敌人，在这种情况下，我们在审讯方法上不应该过分洁身自爱、畏首畏尾。所以他们在同僚面前对此毫不掩饰、供认不讳。当然，他们无法将此事
times, if I as a Catholic were living in Ulster today, I confess I would have one savage and irrational ambition to see Mr. Mordling pressed against a wall for hours on end with a hood over his head. It's a funny image because Mordling would of course be absolutely wasted. Hearing nothing but the noise of a wind machine, deprived of sleep when the noise temporarily ceases by the bland voice of a politician telling him his brain will suffer no irreparable damage. So all this, of course, is a gift to Britain's critics. It's a gift to people like Ted Kennedy in America, you know,
瞒过去。他们居然以为能瞒得住，这太惊人了。《星期日泰晤士报》进行了深入调查。《星期日泰晤士报》的“深度报道”团队列举了11起独立的酷刑案。政府委托三名法官撰写了一份报告。其中两名法官认为这没问题，但第三名法官加德纳勋爵表示，这些技术是秘密的、非法的、在道德上是不正当的，并且与我至今仍认为是世界上最伟大的民主国家的传统格格不入。我看得出来，如果他这样措辞，那他当时就已经不再相信英国是世界上最伟大的民主国家了。是的，我的意思是，当一个法官说出这样的话时，就没有回头路了。你知道，你彻底完蛋了。特德·希思在该报告出炉后立即表示，好吧，没问题，我们以后再也不会使用这些技术了。不过，格雷厄姆·格林实际上写过一封非常精彩的信。格雷厄姆·格林当时对《泰晤士报》写道，如果我作为一个天主教徒今天生活在阿尔斯特，我承认我将有一个残酷且不理智的野心——看到莫德林先生几个小时被死死按在墙上，头上还套着一个头套。这是一个滑稽的画面，因为莫德林当然会被折磨得精疲力竭。
great champion of the Irish-American lobby. But it also is a gift to people in Britain on the radical left, who do agree with this thing, this stuff about Vietnam, who do see it as a morality story of brutal imperialists and heroic martyrs. So this is a point, 1971 or so, where you have marches in the streets in London that are kind of conflating loads of causes at once. The omnicors.
只能听到风力机的噪音，当噪音短暂停止时，又被一个政客温和的声音剥夺睡眠，告诉他他的大脑不会受到不可逆转的损伤。所以这一切，当然，是送给英国批评者的一份大礼。这是送给美国特德·肯尼迪这样的人的一份大礼，你知道的，爱尔兰裔美国人游说集团的伟大拥护者。但这同时也是送给英国激进左翼人士的一份大礼，他们确实赞同关于越南的那些论调，确实将这视为一个关于残酷帝国主义者与英勇烈士的道德故事。所以，大约在1971年左右，伦敦街头出现了这样的游行，它们同时将许多不同的诉求交织在了一起。全能合唱团。
Omnicors. So my favourite placard, Gay Liberation Front supports battle for freedom in Ireland. Now, this would appeal to you, I know, with your Beatles enthusiasm, because you will know that the two best-known Beatles were great enthusiasts for the Troops Out movement at this point. So John Lennon would go on Marches. He reached an album in 72 sometime in New York City, which had two songs about Ireland.
全能合唱团。所以，我最喜欢的标语是：“同性恋解放阵线支持爱尔兰争取自由的斗争”。现在，这肯定会吸引你，我懂，因为你对披头士乐队充满热情，你会知道，披头士最知名的两名成员当时都是“撤军运动”的狂热拥护者。所以约翰·列侬会去参加游行。他在1972年的某个时候在纽约发行了一张专辑，里面有两首关于爱尔兰的歌。
That's his worst album by Miles. It has to be said. And of course, Wings, the band The Beatles could have been. Their debut single. Their debut single. Yeah. Give Ireland back to the Irish. Yes.
那是他相差最远的烂专辑。必须得承认这一点。当然还有“翅膀”乐队（Wings），那个披头士本可以成为的乐队。他们的出道单曲。他们的出道单曲。是的。
Give Ireland back to the Irish. Well, so you know that the guitar. In the forest in wings, Henry McCulloch was a Protestant from Londonderry, I guess we should call it. Wow. And his brother, I think, got beaten up in an Irish pub and Kilburn about it. About the song? Yeah. And Henry McCulloch kind of didn't go back to Northern Ireland for years and years because he would say worried about their reaction.
《把爱尔兰还给爱尔兰人》。好吧，所以你知道那把吉他。在“翅膀”乐队的森林里，亨利·麦卡洛克是来自伦敦德里（我想我们应该这样称呼它）的新教徒。哇。而且我想他的兄弟在基尔本的一家爱尔兰酒吧里因为这首歌被人殴打过。是因为这首歌吗？对。亨利·麦卡洛克好多年都没有回北爱尔兰，因为他说他担心大家的反应。
Yeah. Because Paul and Linda had talked him into this song against his will. I think Paul hadn't even discussed it with him. I think, you know, he thought, oh. that's insane. I'm not sure about this. But anyway, actually the thing about British opinion, I mean, this will, I think, surprise Irish listeners
是的。因为保罗和琳达是在他极不情愿的情况下劝说他唱这首歌的。我想保罗甚至都没有跟他商量过。我想，你知道的，他当时想，哦，这太疯狂了。我对这事可拿不准。不过，说实话，关于英国民众的看法，我的意思是，这恐怕会令爱尔兰听众
and maybe some American listeners. It's the one thing I think that people often get wrong about this story abroad. People I think abroad, and I remember this when I lived in America, people would ask me about Northern Ireland. And I would say, no one in Britain cares about it at all.
以及一些美国听众感到惊讶。我认为这是人们在海外谈论这个故事时经常弄错的一点。我认为在海外的人——当我在美国生活时我记得很清楚——人们会向我询问关于北爱尔兰的事。而我会说，英国根本没有人关心这事。
And they would say, oh, no, that's not right. People in Britain have an irrational attachment to the only thing. of part of the island of Ireland. Most people in Britain, I mean, you will know this, Tom, you lived during this period, genuinely could not care less about this subject. And in fact, even doing this podcast, there's part of me that thinks, will we have any downloads because all our British listeners will say, no, too dull.
而他们会说，哦，不，那不对。英国人对爱尔兰岛唯一的那部分土地有一种不理智的情结。英国大多数人——汤姆，你经历过这段时期，你一定知道——其实对这个话题可以说是漠不关心。事实上，甚至在做这个播客的时候，我心里都有一个声音在想：我们会有下载量吗？因为所有英国听众都会说，不，太无聊了。
I'm not going to listen to this. It's depressing, I think. Yeah. But the main feeling, it was background noise of bombs and assassinations. And you just thought, oh, just make it stop. Yeah. It was the case even from the beginning. So September 1969, when the troops had just gone in, and you would think it would have at least the sort of novelty value, people were asked to rank the problems facing the British government and they unearingly ranked Northern Ireland as bottom least important.
我才不听呢。我觉得这很沉闷。是的。但主要的感受是，它只是伴随着炸弹和暗杀的背景噪音。而你只会想，哦，快让它停下来吧。是的。其实从一开始就是这样。所以在1969年9月，当时军队刚刚介入，你可能会觉得它至少还有点新鲜感，但当人们被要求给英国政府面临的问题进行重要性排序时，他们毫不意外地把北爱尔兰排在了最底部，认为是最不重要的。
But the thing is, the British government, do you think would have agreed with that or not? By this point, is it higher up? Ted Heath spends a lot of time on this. I mean, people are dying, you know? It's a serious thing. It's a low-level civil war. Is it as important to him as getting into the common market? No, nothing is as important.
但问题是，你认为英国政府会同意这种看法吗？到了这个时候，它排得更靠前了吗？特德·希思在这上面花了大量时间。我的意思是，有人在丧命，你知道吗？这是一件严重的事情。这是一场低烈度的内战。这对他的重要性比加入欧洲共同体更重要吗？不，没有什么比这更重要了。
I mean, to be fair to Ted Heath, Ted Heath has the most bonkers cascade of events and challenges. But it is remarkable. It's never an election issue. It never features in election campaigns. It's almost never mentioned at party political conferences. It rarely comes up on TV. It comes to seem like bad weather in February.
公平地说，特德·希思面临着最疯狂的一连串事件和挑战。但这也确实引人注目。它从来都不是一个选举议题。它从未在竞选活动中出现过。在政党大会上几乎从不在被提及。在电视上也极少出现。它感觉就像2月份的恶劣天气一样平常。
Yeah. It's just what you expect. You don't like it, but you just put up with it. Yeah, I think that's true. But anyway, Ted Heath, I mean, you asked about Ted Heath, Ted Heath cannot now ignore it, because after the disaster of internment, things go from very, very bad to absolutely horrendous.
是的。这就是你所预料会发生的事。你虽然不喜欢它，但也只能逆来顺受。是的，我想这确实是真的。不过无论如何，特德·希思——我的意思是，你刚才问到了特德·希思——特德·希思现在无法再忽视它了，因为在拘禁行动酿成灾难之后，局势从非常非常糟糕急转直下，变得彻头彻尾的骇人听闻。
So it's now mid-August, 1971, there's a dramatic increase in the bloodshed. Four people shot on the 11th, a Protestant shot on the 12th, the Catholic shot on the 13th, the soldier killed by the IRA and the 14th. You know, it's now becoming a daily occurrence that people are dying.
现在是1971年8月中旬，流血事件急剧增加。11日4人中枪，12日一名新教徒中枪，13日一名天主教徒中枪，14日一名士兵被爱尔兰共和军杀害。你知道，现在人们丧生已经成了家常便饭。
And we'll end with this, I mean, talk about a concatenation of events, with this absolute sort of drumbeat, of horror in the autumn of 1971. So it starts on Wednesday the 29th of September. It's 10.30 at night and we're in the four-step in, which is a Protestant pub, off the Shankill Road. And it is packed with people watching TV in the pub lounge.
我们就以此结束吧，我的意思是，谈到一连串的事件，伴随着1971年秋天这种绝对可以说是恐怖的鼓点。故事始于9月29日星期星期三。当时是晚上10点半，我们身处“四步酒吧”（Four Step Inn），这是一个位于尚基尔路（Shankill Road）附近的新教徒酒吧。酒吧休息室里挤满了看电视的人。
And then a bomb goes off. And the bar roof collapses. Almost 30 people are injured and two of them are killed. Alexander Andrews and Ernie Bates. Alexander Andrews was 60. He was so badly disfigured by the bomb that his son had to identify. him by his shoes. And nobody claimed responsibility for this, but there's no doubt whatsoever that it was done
然后一枚炸弹爆炸了。酒吧屋顶坍塌。将近30人受伤，其中两人丧生，分别是亚历山大·安德鲁斯和厄尼·贝茨。亚历山大·安德鲁斯当时60岁。他被炸得面目全非，以至于他的儿子不得不通过他的鞋子来辨认他的尸体。
by the provisional IRA. And, you know, this pub is not a military target. This is the first time, really, that you get a bombing that is purely a sectarian attack. So that really is damning their souls then? Completely, completely. Then the 2nd of November, they strike again. This time, the Red Lion on the Ormo Road. 4.30 in the afternoon.
没有人宣称对这起事件负责，但毫无疑问，这就是临时爱尔兰共和军干的。而且，你知道，这家酒吧并不是一个军事目标。这真的是第一次发生纯粹出于宗派袭击目的的爆炸案。所以这真的让他们万劫不复了吗？彻底完了，彻底完了。接着在11月2日，他们再次发动袭击。这一次，目标是奥莫路（Ormo Road）上的红狮酒吧（Red Lion）。下午4点半。
People are in the pub having a drink. two men walk into the pub with a third man with a gun and the two men put down this bomb I mean they literally carry in the bomb and then they say to the people in the pub you've got ten seconds to get out and then they get out themselves the bomb actually went off after six seconds
人们正在酒吧里喝着酒。两个男人带着第三个拿着枪的男人走进了酒吧，然后这两个男人放下了一个炸弹——我的意思是他们真的是把炸弹扛了进去——接着他们对酒吧里的人说，你们有十秒钟的时间逃命，然后他们自己也逃了出去。炸弹实际上在六秒钟后就爆炸了。
again the roof fell in dozens of people injured three people killed John Cochran Mary Gemmel and William Jordan who were all Protestants at this point the Ulster volunteer force get their revenge a month afterwards Saturday the fourth of December, 1971.
屋顶再次塌落，几十人受伤，三人丧生：约翰·科克兰、玛丽·杰梅尔和威廉·乔丹，他们当时都是新教徒。就在一个月后的1971年12月4日星期六，阿尔斯特志愿军（UVF）进行了报复。
McGurk's Bar in the city centre. Kind of pub where old men are sitting round over a pint looking at the newspaper and talking about the horse racing. 8.45 that evening, a UVF man, so a loyalist. Walks into the pub entrance and he drops a brown parcel and then he runs back to a waiting car.
市中心的麦格克酒吧（McGurk's Bar）。那是一种老人们围坐在一起喝着一品脱啤酒、看着报纸并谈论赛马的传统酒吧。当天晚上8点45分，一名乌夫（UVF）成员，也就是一名保罗派，走进了酒吧入口，放下了一个棕色包裹，然后跑回了一辆等候着的汽车。
The parcel is a bomb which explodes almost immediately. It destroys the entire building. 15 people are killed and this includes McGurk, the landlord's wife and his 14-year-old daughter and a 13-year-old boy. So it's escalating. And then a week after that, the IRA take their revenge. So it's tip for tat.
这个包裹是一个炸弹，几乎立刻就爆炸了。整栋建筑被彻底摧毁。15人丧生，其中包括酒吧老板麦格克的妻子、他14岁的女儿以及一个13岁的男孩。所以暴力在不断升级。紧接着一周后，爱尔兰共和军进行了报复。所以这是以牙还牙。
And this is a terrible story. Saturday lunchtime, the Shankill Road, packed with shoppers. A car pulls up outside the Bar Moral Furniture Showroom, and a man jumps out and he puts a box down on the doorstep and then the car speeds off. A few seconds later, this box. explodes and it again destroys the entire building. 20 people are buried under the rubble. Four people are killed straight away. Two of them were staff in the showroom. The other two people who were killed were Tracy Munn and Colin Nicol. Tracy Munn was two and Colin Nicol was 17 months old and they were sharing a pram when they were killed. It's an absolutely horrendous scene. Loads of people
这是一个极其悲惨的故事。周六午餐时间，尚基尔路挤满了购物的人群。一辆汽车在“巴莫尔家具展厅”（Bar Moral Furniture Showroom）门外停下，一个男人跳下车，把一个盒子放在门廊上，随后汽车疾驰而去。几秒钟后，这个盒子爆炸了，再次将整栋建筑摧毁。20人被埋在废墟之下。4人当场身亡。其中两人是展厅的工作人员。另外两名丧生的死者是特蕾西·芒恩（Tracy Munn）和科林·尼科尔（Colin Nicol）。特蕾西·芒恩两岁，科林·尼科尔17个月大，他们遇害时正合坐一辆婴儿车。现场景象绝对惨不忍睹。许多人
come running up and one of them is a boy. He's 15. He's called Billy McQuiston. He heard the bomb and he came running up. And he later told the BBC reporter Peter Taylor, he said, women were crying, men were trying to dig out the rubble. Other men were hitting the walls. I just stood there and cried, just totally and utterly numb. It wasn't until I got back home that I realized this isn't a game. There's a war going on here. These people are trying to do us all in because we're Protestants. They're going to kill us. So we're going to have to do something. And so the next day this 15-year-old boy goes to find the loyalist UDA and that evening they signed him up. And that was how it worked.
跑了过来，其中一个是15岁的男孩，名叫比利·麦奎斯顿（Billy McQuiston）。他听到了爆炸声便跑了过来。他后来告诉BBC记者彼得·泰勒，他说：“女人们在哭泣，男人们在拼命挖掘废墟。还有些男人们在疯狂砸墙。我只是站在那里哭泣，整个人完全麻木了。直到我回到家里，我才意识到这不是一场游戏。这里正在发生一场战争。这些人正试图置我们于死地，只因为我们是新教徒。他们要杀光我们。所以我们必须做点什么。”于是第二天，这个15岁的男孩去找了保罗派的乌防协（UDA），当天晚上他就加入了他们。事情就是这样运作的。
That was how it went on. So this was the United Kingdom in December, 1971. So we've seen how the atrocities have been escalating. And in 1972, things are going to get even worse because the conflict is going to be reaching its deadly peak. So in our final episode of this series, Bloody Sunday in Derry, Bloody Friday in Belfast, and Stormont, the Parliament of Northern Ireland will be getting mothballed. Club members can hear that episode now. You can sign up at the rest of history.com. There will be lots about this series in our incredible newsletter. You can sign up for that as well if you haven't already. Thank you, Dominic. We will be about.
事情就是这样发展下去的。这就是1971年12月的联合王国。所以我们已经看到了暴行是如何不断升级的。而在1972年，局势将变得更加糟糕，因为冲突将迎来其致命的巅峰。因此，在我们本系列的最后一集中，德里的血腥星期日、贝尔法斯特的血腥星期五，以及北爱尔兰议会所在地斯托蒙特都将被束之高阁。俱乐部的会员现在就可以收听那一集了。你可以在therestis history.com网站上注册。我们的精彩新闻简讯中也会有很多关于这个系列的内容。如果你还没有注册，现在也可以注册。谢谢你，多米尼克。我们将随最后一集
with our final episode. Until then, goodbye. Bye-bye. 9-11 was the deadliest terrorist attack in US history. But could it have been prevented? I'm Gordon Carrera, National Security Journalist. And I'm David McCloskey, former CIA analyst, where the hosts of the rest is classified. In our latest series, we are telling the inside story of how the 9-11 terrorists slipped through the CIA's grasp. In the summer of 2000, a man walks up to US immigration at Newark Airport. His passport gets stamped, he's waved through and welcomed to America.
与大家见面。在此之前，再见。再见。9·11事件是美国历史上最致命的恐怖袭击。但这场悲剧本可以避免吗？我是国家安全记者戈登·卡雷拉。我是前中情局分析师大卫·麦克洛斯基。我们是《真相已被解密》（The Rest is Classified）的主持人。在我们最新的系列节目中，我们将独家揭秘9·11恐怖分子是如何漏过中情局的法眼的。2000年夏天，一名男子走向纽瓦克机场的美国移民局。他的护照被盖了章，随后获准通行，并被欢迎来到美国。
That single stamp was one of the gravest intelligence blunders in modern history. Because one year later, nearly 3,000 people will be dead. That man was Muhammad Atta, the ringleader of 9-11. But here's what they don't tell you. The CIA already knew Al-Qaeda was inside the US. An FBI memo explicitly warned that terrorists were in U.S. US flight schools. So how did he slip through? Why was this red flag ignored? In this series, we dig into the declassified files to uncover how the biggest terrorist attack on America was allowed
那个简单的盖章是现代史上最严重的情报失误之一。因为一年后，将近3,000人丧生。那个人就是穆罕默德·阿塔，9·11事件的头目。但以下是他们没有告诉你的是：中情局当时已经知道基地组织潜入了美国。一份联邦调查局（FBI）的备忘录明确警告称，恐怖分子已经潜入了美国的飞行学校。那么他是如何漏网的呢？为什么这个危险信号被忽视了？在本系列节目中，我们将深入挖掘解密文件，揭开美国史上最大恐怖袭击是如何被放任发生的。
to happen. Get the full story by listening to The Rest is Classified and subscribing to the Declassified Club wherever you get your podcasts. Hi, everybody, Dominic again. Now, here is the clip that we promised to you from our show The Book Club, which talks about Ernest Hempherson. Mingway's book for whom the bell tolls and specifically the history of the Spanish Civil War. So Spain has not been involved in the First World War at all. It's been a backwater, basically. It's been really politically turbulent. There is a king. It's normally a parliamentary system. Most of Spain is untouched by the modern world. So it feels like there's these huge estates called the Latifundiae, which go back to the Roman period. I found this extraordinary. I had no idea until I started reading
无论你在哪里收听播客，只需订阅《真相已被解密》并加入“解密俱乐部”（Declassified Club），即可收听完整故事。大家好，我是多米尼克。现在，这是我们向大家承诺的来自节目《读书俱乐部》（The Book Club）的剪辑，其中谈到了欧内斯特·海明威的书《战地钟声》，特别是西班牙内战的历史。所以西班牙根本没有卷入第一次世界大战。它基本上是一个被世人遗忘的角落。它的政治局势非常动荡。那里有一个国王。通常实行议会制。西班牙的大部分地区都没有受到现代世界的影响。所以感觉那里有被称为“大庄园”（Latifundiae）的巨大地产，可以追溯到罗马时期。我觉得这太不可思议了。在开始阅读相关资料之前，我对此一无所知。
for this. Well, this is true of Spain and Portugal, actually. They would have absolutely gigantic rural estates run by landowners, almost a kind of feudal system. The peasants are enthralled to the landowner and to the church and whatnot. There are parts of Spain that have industrialized, the Basque Country, the North and Catalonia, but those are obviously places with separatist movements. So Spain feels very fractured, and there's lots of labour unrest, there's a big anarchist movement, there is a socialist movement. There's a communist party. In the 20s, there was a coup and a general took power called General Miguel Primo de Rivera, you know, under the king. But that didn't really work out. They brought back democracy at the beginning of the 1930s, but it's incredibly polarized and
嗯，这其实也适用于西班牙和葡萄牙。它们拥有由地主经营的绝对巨大的农村地产，几乎是一种封建制度。农民们依附于地主、教会等等。西班牙有一些地区已经实现了工业化，比如巴斯克地区、北部和加泰罗尼亚，但这些地方显然都有分裂主义运动。所以西班牙感觉非常分裂，有大量的劳工动乱，有一个庞大的无产阶级无政府主义运动，还有一个社会主义运动。还有一个共产党。在20世纪20年代，发生了一场政变，一位名叫米格尔·普里莫·德里维拉（Miguel Primo de Rivera）的将军在国王手下夺取了政权，你知道的。但那并没有真正起作用。他们在20世纪30年代初恢复了民主，但社会极度两极分化。
unstable between right and left. There are terrible strikes. So, for example, in the north in 1935. There are assassinations. There are kind of paramilitary movements and whatnot. The son of the previous dictator, Prima de Rivera, sets up a little fascist party called the Falange, which actually sort of gives its name really to, it's then co-opted by the rights, by the conservatives who win the Spanish Civil War. I mean, whether they're really fascists or whether they're just basically using the fascist label is an interesting question. Right. So it all comes to head in 1936. There's an election at the beginning of the year, which means that a popular front, which is a kind of left-wing alliance of liberals, socialists, you know, sort of left-wing parties, some of the separatists,
右翼和左翼之间很不稳定。发生了可怕的罢工。例如，在1935年的北部。发生了暗杀事件。有各种准军事运动等等。前独裁者普里莫·德里维拉的儿子建立了一个名为“长枪党”的小法西斯政党，这个党名实际上后来被赢得西班牙内战的右翼保守派所借用。我的意思是，他们究竟是真的法西斯分子，还是基本上只是在利用法西斯标签，这是一个有趣的问题。对。所以这一切在1936年达到了高潮。年初举行了一场选举，这意味着人民阵线——一个由自由主义者、社会主义者、左翼政党以及一些分离主义分子或来自巴斯克地区、加泰罗尼亚等地的民族主义团体组成的左翼联盟——上台了。
or more nationalist groups from the areas like the Basque Country or Catalonia, they come to power. And there's a lot of social unrest because they want to push through radical changes and the right don't like that. And in July 1936, the army launches right-wing elements within the army launch a coup. The reason the Spanish Civil War happens is the coup doesn't fully work. So basically, the trade unions, the big cities in Madrid, Barcelona and so on, stay loyal to the elected government. So Spain is divided between the rebels, the coup people in the army and their allies who are often like big landowners, the Catholic Church and so on, who want to defend the status quo. they've got half the country, often kind of rural areas, more conservative and so on.
或者来自巴斯克和加泰罗尼亚等地区的民族主义团体上台了。社会动荡不安，因为他们希望推行激进的变革，而右翼对此非常不满。1936年7月，军队内部的右翼分子发动了政变。西班牙内战之所以爆发，是因为政变并没有完全成功。基本上，马德里、巴塞罗那等大城市的工会依然忠于民选政府。于是西班牙分裂为两派：一方是军队中的叛军、政变策划者及其盟友（通常是大土地所有者、天主教会等，他们想要维护现状，控制了大约半个国家，多为保守的农村地区等）；
But the big cities and Catalonia and so on, so Madrid, Barcelona, places like that, they stay loyal to the elected government. So on the one hand, you have what are called the nationalists, and these are the forces of the right, the army, the coup plotters and so on. effectively from day one they have very very strong international backing from Mussolini in Italy and then Hitler in Germany and then on the left you have the elected government who are the Republicans and they get help eventually from the Soviet Union which is something of a poison chalice and they do appeal to Britain and France for help but they don't really get it and they have help from foreign volunteers and this war becomes incredibly bitter and incredibly bloody.
但大城市、加泰罗尼亚以及马德里、巴塞罗那等地则忠于民选政府。一方面，有所谓的国民军，即右翼力量、军队、政变策划者等。从第一天起，他们就得到了来自意大利墨索里尼以及后来德国希特勒非常强有力的国际支持；另一方面，在左翼这边，有民选政府，即共和国派，他们最终得到了苏联的援助（这有点像一杯毒酒），他们确实向英国和法国寻求帮助，但并没有真正得到，他们还得到了外国志愿者的帮助，这场战争变得异常残酷和血腥。
I mean, this is always the way it was civil wars because people feel it's an existential struggle, the future of their country is at stake. They come to believe, you know, their neighbours, the people in the next town, the landowners or the priests or the anarchists or whoever are going to kill them in their families, so we've got to kill them first.
我的意思是，内战一向如此，因为人们觉得这是一场生死存亡的斗争，国家的未来悬于一线。他们开始相信，他们的邻居、隔壁小镇的人、地主、牧师、无政府主义者或其他任何人会杀死他们和他们的家人，所以我们必须先下手为强。
People, in some places, there are horrendous, horrendous, sadistic massacres and things. I think they found something like, at the end of, maybe the start of the 21st century or something, that Spain had the highest number of mass graves after Cambodia. So if you want to hear the full episode, just go to Apple or Spotify or YouTube and search for The Book Club.
在某些地方，发生了可怕的、极其虐待性的惨案。我想他们发现，在21世纪初左右，西班牙的乱葬岗数量仅次于柬埔寨。如果你想收听完整的单集，只需前往 Apple、Spotify 或 YouTube 搜索 The Book Club。
And there it is. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
就是这样。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。